So this is me, flying solo on a cold open. I don't know if I've done this before. I think maybe I've done this before. It's not great. What you're going to find in the next few seconds is why this show works with three and not with one. It might work with just Will or just Sean, but not just me. It's just not enough. It's like one hand trying to clap.
这就是我，冷开场一个人单干。我不知道我以前有没有这么干过。我觉得我以前可能干过。这感觉不太好。接下来的几秒钟里，你们会发现为什么这个节目需要三个人而不是一个人。也许威尔自己来或者肖恩自己来还行，但只有我一个人可不行。这实在不够。就像一只手在拍巴掌。
It's just, it's not possible. It sounds like this. You want to know what it sounds like? One hand clapping? It's terrible, right? It's not entertaining at all. So let me bring in the other two hands and let's light this candle. Here we come.
这根本，这根本不可能。听起来是这样的。你们想知道听起来是什么样吗？单手拍巴掌？很糟糕，对吧？一点也不好笑。所以，让我请出另外两只手，把这个节目热烈地开场吧。我们来啦。
Smart. Wait, how's everybody doing today? It's morning where you are, Jay. It's so good. JJ. It is. It's morning and I'm still a little foggy from last night. I had a little too much sugar last night.
太棒了。等等，大家今天过得怎么样？你那边还是早上吧，杰。太好了。JJ。确实是。现在是早上，我昨晚宿醉未消，脑子还有点糊涂。我昨晚糖吃得有点多。
Oh, no. I have a sensitive system. Did you go to Sunday, Funday? Yeah, we had a little peach cobbler for dessert. And it was great. It was really, I was saying as I was driving home with Amanda, saying, you know, love, love the groups there. but you just can't replace Sean or Will
哦，不会吧。我的体质比较敏感。你昨天去过“周日狂欢”吗？对，我们昨晚吃了点桃子馅饼当甜点。感觉太棒了。真的，我在和阿曼达开车回家的路上还在说，你知道的，我很喜欢那里的团队，但你就是无法取代肖恩或威尔
in a party dynamic, you know? You can try. You can try. We've got your head shots there on a couple of C-Stans, but it just doesn't work. On C-stance. Still, by the way, still, by the way, you could put cake on the picture and the headshot
在聚会时的那种氛围，你知道吗？你可以试着取代。你可以试试。我们在几个C型支架上放了你们俩的大头照，但就是行不通。在C型支架上。不过话说回来，就算你在照片或大头照上
and I'd still probably enjoy it. Somehow your picture would come to life and eat it up. It's like voodoo. Sean, all of a sudden you'd like feel a warmth in your stomach. Speaking of voodoo, I watched weapons for the third time last night. I can't wait to see it.
抹上一层蛋糕，我大概还是会觉得挺享受。不知怎么的，你的照片会活过来把它吃掉。就像巫术一样。肖恩，你突然会感觉到胃里暖洋洋的。说起巫术，我昨晚第三次看了《武器》。我等不及要看了。
Man, big fan of that movie. That's Zach McGregor. You keep saying how good it is. And you watch with Franny? Franny, soaked it up, loved it. It's a real director's accomplishment. Well, Franny's going away to start. She's going away to college.
天哪，我很喜欢那部电影。那是扎克·麦格雷戈的作品。你一直在说它有多好看。你是和弗兰妮一起看的吗？弗兰妮，看得津津有味，非常喜欢。这绝对是导演的一大成就。哦，弗兰妮要离家去开启新生活了。她要去上大学了。
She's going away to college. I know. The next couple days. Tomorrow. No way. Yes. She's going locally here to university here in Los Angeles. and so so there might not be tears i think if i think if i was to fly her somewhere and then fly
她要去上大学了。我知道。就在这几天。明天。不会吧。是的。她就在本地上学，在洛杉矶的大学。所以，所以可能不会掉眼泪。我想如果我把她飞机送到外地然后飞
away it would be really yeah but it's nice you don't think that you're going to have tears i don't think i'm going to have tears no because look you know as any parents out at an early range yeah but you know 17 year olds 18 year olds they they end up doing a lot of sleepouts anyway so you know she's sort of like living here three days a week anyway okay sleep outs sleep outs sleep outs sleep outs what's the hell's a sleep out sleepover over over's yeah sleep out hey can you come over for a sleepout what are you going to sleep around a lawn Sean were you was it teary when you left did your mom shed tears out of her one eye when you left for college I think the other one still cried it just didn't see in the box it was in the box I opened the box later it was so
回来，可能会真的……是的，不过挺好的，你觉得你不会掉眼泪吗？我觉得我不会掉眼泪，不。因为你看，当父母的在很早的阶段就经历过了，对吧？但你知道的，17岁、18岁的孩子，他们最后无论如何都会经常在外面过夜。所以你知道的，她基本上每周有三天都住在这里，好吧。过夜，过夜，过夜，过夜。到底什么是过夜？就是留宿过夜啊。嘿，你能来我家过夜吗？你打算在草坪上过夜吗？肖恩，你离开家上大学时哭了吗？你妈送你上大学时，眼角流眼泪了吗？我觉得她另一只眼还在哭，只是没看见。它装在盒子里。当时在盒子里。我后来打开盒子才发现。
pooling it was pooling in the box no I remember move I remember my moving day for college though it was like it was like a hundred degrees out it was everybody just couldn't wait to be done with everybody it was just like get out it's gonna be a hundred tomorrow we're shipping furniture up two flights of stairs is that what it was with you just like carrying crap uh who'd you pay to do it yeah exactly no it's uh it's gonna be me and amanda and maple is it really yeah three cars worth of stuff can i just say that were i there and it there's not a hollow offer because i'm not i would help i would tell by the way i would very safe offer that i know it is but it's true but it's true i love the thousands of miles away i know but it is true it was college was the best time
里面都积水了。盒子都积水了。不过我记得我上大学搬家那天，天热得像有一百度。每个人都巴不得赶紧把事情弄完各奔东西。就好像是“快滚吧”。明天温度又要飙到一百度了，我们还要把家具搬上两层楼梯。你当年也是这样的吗？搬着一堆破烂，呃，你花钱雇人搬的吗？对，完全是。不，这次得我和阿曼达还有梅普尔一起来。真的吗？三车的东西。我能说句吗，如果我在那儿的话——这不是一句空话，因为我不在——我会帮忙的。顺便说一句，这是一个非常安全的承诺，我知道是这样，但这是真的，但这是真的。我太喜欢几千英里之外的……我知道，但这是真的，大学绝对是人生中最美好的时光。
in life i loved it you know i remember um before you peaked in college i did i i remember my brother mike was so impatient that before you could before computers and everything and you had a you had a sign up for classes he drove the car there was a line from the building whatever it is the administrative building where you sign up for glasses all the way down the entire street it was like a thousand people waiting in line to sign it for class he drove the car right up on the lawn got me out walked right up to the front and said hey i need to sign my brother up for classes and like well there's a line she's like yeah i know but we were registered to come in we had an appointment and she just lied his way and she just bullshit it right away that sounds like me trying to get an
我太爱它了。我记得，嗯……在你大学生活达到巅峰之前，我记得我哥哥迈克太性急了。在没有电脑和那些东西的年代，你需要排队选课，他把车直接开到那儿。从那栋楼——随便哪栋楼，就是你选课的行政大楼——一直排到整条街都是人。大概有一千人在排队等着选课。他直接把车开到草坪上，让我下车，一直走到队伍最前面，然后说：“嘿，我要给我弟弟选课。”对方说：“嗯，这里排着队呢。”他说：“对，我知道，但我们是预约好今天来注册的。”然后他硬生生地撒谎，直接把这事给糊弄过去了。这听起来就像我想去弄台
iPhone no what do you mean jason don't bring it up don't let people google jason baitman's jumping line for iPhone in 2007 wait what happened wait well was it really really 2007 you're amazing yeah so wait what month was it uh that's a good question i that i don't know i'm gonna say the fall but you can give a good yeah because they usually release in the fall yeah a good guess but jb you know you got the year down is that right yeah well that's a year after they came out right yeah that's the year they came out uh shawney so you know the story is jb and i you know the people the the nice people at apple had sort of said hey we'll set you up with the phone and jason said you know what? I'm going to go to the grove
iPhone时的情景。不，你这话什么意思，杰森？别提这事。别让人去谷歌“杰森·贝特曼2007年排队买iPhone”。等等，发生什么了？等等，真的真的是2007年吗？你太厉害了。所以，等一下，那是哪个月？嗯，这倒是个好问题。我不记得了。我猜是秋季，不过你可以猜个准。因为他们通常在秋季发布。真是个不错的猜测，JB，你连年份都记住了，对吗？对，那是产品问世的一年后吧？对，就是他们推出的那一年。肖尼，你知道这个故事是这样的，JB和我，苹果公司的那些好心人曾对我说：“嘿，我们帮你搞一部手机。”然后杰森说：“你知道吗？我要去格罗夫购物中心，
and I'm going to be a regular guy and I'm going to wait in line and get my... I'm so excited. Romanticizing the whole queuing up, you know, like Star Wars and Empire Strikes Back, you know, and everyone's like line up. So I was like, okay, and I was like, I'm going to get mine delivered to my house a week early. Anyways, which I did.
我要当一个普通人，我要排队去拿我的……我太兴奋了。”浪漫化了整个排队过程，你知道的，就像《星球大年》和《帝国反击战》那样，每个人都得排队。所以我就想，好吧。然后我就想，我要提前一个星期把手机送到我家。不管怎样，我也确实这么做了。
J.V. goes down, God bless him. God bless this little boy. He goes down to the Grove and he's waiting in line, all excited and diligently, right? And he's there. And the employees at the Apple store there go, hey look that's jason baitman line so they go out to him and they go hey man don't wait here come come with us so he kind of like obliges out of being polite and he goes with them they bring him into the store and he gets a phone early well wouldn't you know the daily and daily mail or whoever paparice are taking photos of people lining up and the story comes out jason baitman skips line jumped the line i love that the story the story's out before i get back to the office right willie i got to the office and it was already online and you say hey man I was, I was giddy jumping out of...
JB去了，上帝保佑他。上帝保佑这个小男孩。他去了格罗夫购物中心，兴奋而又勤勤恳恳地排着队，对吧？他就在那儿。那里的苹果店员工看到了，就说：“嘿，看，那是杰森·贝特曼在排队。”于是他们走过去对他说：“嘿，老兄，别在这儿等了，跟我们来吧。”所以他出于礼貌，半推半就地跟他们走了。他们把他带进店里，让他提前拿到了手机。你猜怎么着，每日邮报或某个狗仔队拍下了人们排队的照片，新闻就出来了：“杰森·贝特曼插队，跳过排队。”我喜欢这个，故事在我回到办公室之前就已经传出去了，对吧，威利？我到办公室的时候它已经在网上了。而你说：“嘿，老兄……”我当时得意洋洋地跳出来……
But wait a minute, here's the best part of the story that you didn't want the free phone sent to your house because you wanted to be a real person, then you went in the line and you got out of the line anyway. Well, these nice people were like, hey, and there was a photographer in the bushes that was taking pictures of me anyway, like in line. And so I probably should have put two and two together.
但等一下，这个故事最妙的部分在于：你本不想让免费手机送到你家里，因为你想当个普通人；结果你排了队，最后还是脱离了队伍。好吧，那些好心人当时说：“嘿……”而且灌木丛里正好有个摄影师在拍我排队的照片。所以我想我当时本该把这两件事联系起来的。
God, it was one of the best, honestly, it felt like such a victory to me. And then the next year that they issued a phone, our nice person, at Apple called us and said, hey, so we want to send you a new phone. And we had a staff meeting with, I think it was Tim Cook at the time.
天哪，这绝对是……老实说，我当时觉得这简直是一场伟大的胜利。然后第二年他们发布新手机时，苹果公司的热心人给我们打来电话说：“嘿，我们想给你寄一部新手机。”我们当时开了一个员工会议，好像蒂姆·库克当时也在。
And he said, hey, everybody, let's not pull another Bateman. Let's make sure we get the VIP phones out. No way. I became a verb at the fucking... I love that PR fuck episode, Apple are now called Bateman. No, but they did everything right.
他说：“嘿，各位，咱们别再整出个‘贝特曼事件’了。咱们务必把VIP手机直接送到。”不会吧。我特么居然成了一个动词……我太喜欢苹果公司把那种公关烂事现在叫做“贝特曼”了。不，但他们什么都没做错。
It was me that said, no, thanks again. Oh, gosh. And now on our... Now we have the best cell phones we can listen to our podcast on our cell phone and use smartless mobile. You can use smartless mobile. Why wouldn't you? Because you're going to get less than half.
是我当时说：“不，谢谢，还是算了。”哦，天哪。现在在我们的……现在我们有了最好的手机，我们可以在手机上听播客，并使用智能精简移动通信（Smartless Mobile）。你可以使用智能精简移动通信。你为什么不用呢？因为你会吃亏，连一半都省不到。
Wait, what's smartless mobile? What do you mean? I don't understand. Well, it's a cell phone service. You have a provider. Let's say you have a provider. You have whoever is. One of these big, I guess, if you had to.
等等，什么是智能精简移动通信？什么意思？我不明白。嗯，它是一项手机服务。你有一个运营商。假设你有一个运营商。你有随便哪家。这些大公司之一，我想，如果你非要选的话。
T-Mobile? Yeah, but why not save money? But why not save money? Cheaper? It's less than half. What if I want to keep my number? No problem. Why are you so tired and beleaguered?
T-Mobile？对，但为什么不省点钱呢？为什么不省点钱？更便宜？还不到一半呢。如果我想保留原来的号码呢？没问题。你为什么看起来这么累、这么精疲力竭？
I just feel like, on the outside chance, people haven't heard our pitch, I guess. I'm trying to not be annoying. You keep our number. You can keep your number. It's not as mobile. You can cut your cell phone bill in half, more than half sometimes. A quick sign up? Is that what it is?
我只是觉得，万一有人还没听过我们的广告词呢。我尽量表现得不那么烦人。你可以保留你的号码。你可以保留你的号码。这就是智能精简移动通信。你可以把你的手机话费减半，有时甚至能省下一半以上。注册很快？是这样吗？
It's easy, less than five minutes. Get the app. Jason, do you like apps? I love it. We have a smartest mobile. The best. Go sign up everybody. Okay, let's get to our guest.
很简单，不到五分钟。下载应用程序。杰森，你喜欢应用程序吗？我太喜欢了。我们有了智能精简移动通信。太棒了。大家都去注册吧。好了，让我们有请我们的嘉宾。
Okay. Our guest, by the way, speaking of the best, we i have brought today an absolute heavy weight i'm so excited about this this guy is a just bona fida decades long international superstar okay he is unbelievable he is won an academy award a golden globe multiple grammies academy american music award things he's written so many hit songs he was in a band Then he had an incredible solo career Everyone and then he wrote songs for all the biggest stars And he wrote songs for himself
好的。顺便说一句，说到最棒的，我们今天请来了一位绝对重量级的嘉宾，我太兴奋了。这家伙是一位名副其实、红遍全球数十年的国际巨星。好吧，他简直不可思议，他获得过奥斯卡奖、金球奖、多座格莱美奖、全美音乐奖等等。他写了无数首热门歌曲。他曾经在一个乐队里。然后他迎来了不可思议的个人音乐生涯。每个人都……而且他为所有最大牌的明星写过歌，他还为自己写过歌。
And he had the hugest He's one of the biggest record selling artists of all time And I'm going to start to list some of his Starting with his old band all the way through his other Sean, you better guess this He wrote easy, Ceylon's a lady still He wrote Lady for Kenny Richie You are, yes
他的唱片销量极其惊人。他是史上唱片销量最高的大牌艺术家之一。我要开始列举他的一些……从他老牌乐队开始，一直到他后来的……肖恩，你最好猜猜看。他写过《Easy》，还有《Still》……他为肯尼·罗杰斯写过《Lady》……是你，没错。
And I love all my longest Lionel Richie Oh my God Good morning, sir No way Oh good morning, guys That was The hamming up of the opening was just amazing
我爱死我所有的……最伟大的莱昂内尔·里奇！哦，天哪。早上好，先生。不会吧。哦，早上好，伙计们。刚才开场时那种浮夸的表演真是太棒了。
Jason the story about the cell phone is so embarrassed I know listen Lennel we'd love to welcome to the show but more importantly we'd love to get you sign up with smartless mobile That's true What do you pay a money? Look at this beautiful studio you've got
杰森讲的手机那个故事太让人尴尬了。我懂，听着，莱昂内尔，我们很欢迎你来到节目，但更重要的是，我们很想让你注册智能精简移动通信。真的。你花多少钱？看看你们这儿漂亮的录音室。
there is that the recording studio? It's the recording studio Yeah This is the hideout down here when I want to Get totally away from everybody The doors closed and don't come in You are the man you've been the man for so cool It is such an honor to have you, Mr. Lytle Ritchie here in the show with us.
那是录音室吗？这是录音室。对。这就是我想要彻底摆脱所有人时躲进来的秘密基地。大门一关，谁也别进来。你真是个传奇，你一直是个传奇。莱昂内尔·里奇先生，能请您来到我们的节目，真是莫大的荣幸。
Let me just say, Jason, Sean, and Will, you know, having the three of you in front of me right now is, and listening is just probably the trip of my life because, you know, I really admire the fact that your talent and the, and you can kind of improv so seamlessly. Well, but it's just dribble, you know, it's just talking, you know. You're about to get 50 minutes of it, tuck in. Well, it's such an honor to have you, such a pleasure to have you. So cool. You're here in Los Angeles, yes? I'm in Los Angeles, yes. And you've lived here how long?
我只想说，杰森、肖恩和威尔，此时此刻看到你们三位坐在我面前，听你们说话，这大概是我这辈子最奇妙的经历。因为，你知道的，我真的很佩服你们的才华，以及你们那种天衣无缝的即兴能力。噢，但这其实都是废话，你知道的，就是瞎聊。你接下来要听整整50分钟的废话，做好准备吧。能请到您真是我们的荣幸，太高兴了。太棒了。您现在住在洛杉矶，对吧？我在洛杉矶，是的。您在这里住了多久了？
I feel like I know where your house is, too. I know exactly where your house. I know, too. I've been here since 1981. In the same house? Not in the same house. No, no, no, no, no. I'm doing the, I did the start off in the guest house, then you go from there to the main house,
我觉得我知道你的房子在哪里。我确切知道你的房子在哪。我也知道。我从1981年就住在这儿了。一直住同一栋房子里？不是同一栋房子。不，不，不，不，不。我经历了……我先是从客房住起，然后从那儿搬到主屋，
and then from there, okay, I'm out of here. So, you know, a couple of rentals here and there, and then finally ended up here, beautiful. Where did you start? Where were you born? Where'd you get raised? Tuskegee, Alabama, right on the campus. Really?
再从那儿……好吧，我受够了。所以，你知道的，这期间租过好几次房，最后才定居在这里，非常漂亮。你最初是从哪里开始的？你在哪里出生？在哪里长大的？阿拉巴马州的塔斯基吉，就在校园里。真的吗？
Yeah, so that's right. So you grew up on the campus in Tuskegee. Right on the campus. It was, well, I shouldn't say right on. It was across the street from the gates of the campus. And since then, the campus has surrounded my place, my house. And why is that? There's not, you, your parents, are they still around?
对，没错。所以你是在塔斯基吉的校园里长大的。就在校园里。嗯，其实我不该说“就在”。它在校园大门的正对面。从那以后，校园把我的住处、我的房子给包围了。为什么会这样？你……你的父母还在吗？
Are they still with us? No, no, I'm not, mom, dad, and grandma, but the memories are right there still in the house. I still on the house. Do you really? The house is still on the campus, and people pass by and go, there's Lionel Richie's house. Have they offered to buy the house? Do they want to absorb it and, like, build a new building right there for the school? You know, exactly why I want to hang on to it, because, you know, every time they say, Lionel, that's a wonderful spot.
他们还在世吗？不，不，我妈妈、爸爸和奶奶都不在了，但那些回忆依然留在那栋房子里。我还住在那个房子里。真的吗？那栋房子还在校园里，人们路过时会说：“那是莱昂内尔·里奇的房子。”他们有没有出价买下这栋房子？他们想把它吞并掉，好在那里为学校建一座新建筑吗？你知道，这正是我想要守住它的原因，因为，你知道的，每次他们说：“莱昂内尔，那是个好地方。”
And I go, mm-hmm, tear the house down and put another building up. Uh-huh. We're not going to do that. But actually, I grew up right across the street from the preempt. president of university's house. Oh, my God. And then as time went on, they moved to the big mansion at the other end of the campus. But, I mean, for the longest time, I was there with the...
我就回答：“嗯哼，把房子拆了建个新楼？呃-哈。我们可不打算这么干。”但事实上，我是在大学校长官邸的正对面长大的。天哪。后来随着时间推移，他们搬到了校园另一头的大豪宅去了。不过，讲真，很长一段时间里我都和……
What campus? I don't... The University of Alabama? No, no, no, Tuskegee University. Tuskegee University. And what was your connection? Did you have a connection to Tuskegee University? Did I have a connection?
什么校园？我没……阿拉巴马大学？不，不，不，塔斯基吉大学。塔斯基吉大学。你和它有什么渊源吗？你跟塔斯基吉大学有渊源吗？我有没有渊源？
Oh, my God, guys. It was Tuskegee Airmen. My... This is my... The moms and dads of my whole little group. Number two, believe it or not, on the deed of the house, you've got the Washington family who had the house before my grandmother had it. And so, and grandfather.
天哪，伙计们。那是塔斯基吉飞行员。我的……这是我整个小圈子里所有人的爸爸妈妈。其次，信不信由你，在房子的地契上，在我奶奶拥有它之前，拥有这栋房子的是华盛顿家族。所以，还有我爷爷。
So it was one of those things where it kind of started right there on the campus with everything else. And of course, in 1923 is when they received the house. And I didn't show up at that time, I must assure you that I keep telling my kids, I don't know Abraham Lincoln, but. it was pretty late after that that I showed up but it was wonderful man just to have that history in the house and you went you went to college there right you went to Tuskee oh yeah oh yeah
所以事情就是这样，它和所有其他东西一起，就从校园里开始了。当然，他们是在1923年拿到这栋房子的。我可不是那个时候出生的，我向你们保证，我经常告诉我的孩子们，我不认识亚伯拉罕·林肯，但是……我是在那之后很久才出生的。不过能拥有那段历史保留在房子里，真的很棒，伙计。你是在那儿上大学的对吧？你去了塔斯基……噢，是的，噢，是的。
and that's where you kind of got your that's where you got your start I remember reading this thing you were saying I want to mention that your book is coming out I want to say September 30th your book truly you named it yeah oh that and and is this your first book my first book listen I'm telling you if it takes me the rest of my life, have you ever done a book before?
你就是在那里起步的。我记得读过这样一件事，你说……我想提醒大家，你的书将在9月30日出版，你的书就叫《Truly》（真心），对吧？噢，那……这是你的第一本书吗？我的第一本书。听着，我跟你说，哪怕花光我剩下的时间……你以前写过书吗？
No. No, he's never read a book. It's left to right, top to bottom, right? I'm going to read them a book later on tonight. It's going to be awesome. So let me just tell you that it is painful because they keep asking you, and then what happened? And then you want to kind of go,
没有。没有，他从没读过书。从左到右，从上到下，对吧？我今晚晚点要给他们读本书。那一定棒极了。所以我得告诉你们，这过程挺痛苦的，因为他们一直追问：“然后呢？后来发生了什么？”然后你就会想说：
okay, I don't want to talk about that anymore. How is your recall? Because I figure my recall is going to be so bad. I'm going to have to be in some sort of hypnosis to pull it all out. You know, it all kind of worked out where, you know, the stories kind of fell into place, you know. Once you, between the band, between growing up in Tuskegee, between various episodes of that, and then, of course, meeting and greeting around the world, it kind of fell into place, man.
“好吧，我不想再谈这个了。”你的记忆力怎么样？因为我觉得我的记性太差了。我可能得接受某种催眠才能把这些事全都挖出来。你知道的，这一切最后都挺顺利的，那些故事自然而然地各就各位了。一旦你把乐队、在塔斯基吉成长的经历、各种插曲，当然还有世界各地的所见所闻串联起来，一切就水到渠成了，伙计。
You start calling off names and then the next name shows up. And it takes a minute. Every once in a while you have to make a phone call and go, hey, who was that guy? What was like that lady's name? You have to call somebody that remembers. Who is the most helpful? Jason does that home when his kids walk by. He says to his wife.
你开始报出一个个名字，紧接着下一个名字就浮现了。这需要花点时间。偶尔你得打个电话问问：“嘿，那家伙是谁来着？那个女的叫什么名字？”你得找个还记得的人问问。谁最会帮倒忙？杰森每当他孩子走过时就会这么做。他会问他妻子：
Who's that? Yeah, which was that? Was there one person that was the most helpful for you in recalling some of these things? Yeah, I have a couple of homeboys still in Tuskegee. It calls off the names of everybody in life. Milton Carver Davis was one of them, and Harold Boone is another one. And they just kind of said, oh, no, that's the guy's name. And then, believe it or not, Ronald Lepred from the Commodore has helped me out tremendously
“那是谁？”对，那是谁来着？有没有哪个人对你回忆这些事情最有帮助？对，我在塔斯基吉还有几个老铁。他们能随口叫出生活里所有人的名字。米尔顿·卡弗·戴维斯就是其中之一，哈罗德·布恩是另一个。他们会说：“哦，不，那家伙叫这名儿。”然后，信不信由你，海军准将乐队的罗纳德·勒普雷德对我的帮助极大，
because he kept saying, no, that's not what happened. And then he starts calling it. Because, you know, as time goes on, it becomes, yeah, and I did this. And remember, we did that, and I go, Rich, Rich, you weren't there. Right, right, right. You're making up memories. You're like creating memories. You know, I'm creating my, and remember I came on the stage and I told the crowd, Rich, you weren't there.
因为他一直说：“不，事情不是那样的。”然后他开始讲起细节。因为，你知道的，随着时间推移，记忆会变成：“对啊，我当时做了这个。还记得我们做了那个吗？”然后我说：“里奇，里奇，你当时根本不在场。”对，对，对。你简直是在凭空捏造记忆。你就像是在创造记忆。你知道的，我在创造属于我的……“还记得我走上舞台告诉台下观众……”“里奇，你当时根本不在场。”
Is that your nickname? Yeah, is that what people closest to you call you, Rich? No, they call me actually Skeet is my nickname. Really? Where did that come from? Believe it or not, okay, this is part of that painful book. Okay, so what happens is that, you know, your father walks in the room, looks at the baby, and it goes... Go on.
那是你的绰号吗？对，那是你身边最亲近的人叫你的名字吗，里奇？不，他们其实叫我……Skeet是我的绰号。真的吗？这名字是怎么来的？信不信由你，好吧，这也是那本痛苦的书里的一部分。好吧，事情是这样的，你爸爸走进房间，看着那个婴儿，然后说……说下去。
Sorry, hang on one second. Sean, father is a guy... Sorry. Yeah, so he walks in, there's the baby. You know, and most guys would say, okay, yo, kill a or... Bruce or, you know, come here, give me a rough name. My dad goes, my Ski-Boo. My-Ske-Boo.
抱歉，等一下。肖恩，父亲是一个……抱歉。对，所以他走进来，看到了那个婴儿。你知道的，大多数人会说，好吧，叫基拉或者……布鲁斯，或者，你知道的，过来，给我取个随意的名字。我爸说，我的Ski-Boo。我的-Ske-Boo。
And I said, you know, I even questioned him, I said, dude, of all the names, why Ski-Boo? He said, he just came out that way. Well, anyway, I am now in high school. I carry Ski-Boo all the way through elementary school, which is painful. Painful, I tell you. And then I get to high school, and the guy said, you're going to get killed in high school with Ski-Boo. Yeah. So we're going to change your name to Ski-T, and that was it.
我说，你知道的，我甚至质问他，我说，老兄，这么多名字，为什么叫Ski-Boo？他说，他当时就是那么脱口而出的。好吧，不管怎样，我上高中了。我整个小学都带着Ski-Boo这个名字，这太痛苦了。痛苦，我告诉你。然后我上了高中，那家伙说，你在高中顶着Ski-Boo这个名字会被人笑死的。对。所以我们要把你的名字改成Ski-T，事情就这样定下来了。
And then it was Skeet, it was never Lionel or... No, no, yeah. I like Skeet. That's kind of cool. Let me give you the other name, so you'll know. Anytime you have a guy named Fungus, another guy named Cookie Man, you follow me, so Skeet, I got away cleaning with Skeet, okay. Those are your two other best friends? Oh, no, we had P-Head, we got some days, P-Head, and Sonny Boy, we got some names.
然后就成了Skeet，从来都不是莱昂内尔或者……不，不，对。我喜欢Skeet。这听起来挺酷的。我告诉你另一个名字，这样你就知道了。只要你身边有一个叫Fungus的家伙，另一个叫Cookie Man的家伙，你懂我意思吧，所以Skeet，我顶着Skeet这个名字混过去了，好吧。那是你的另外两个最好的朋友吗？哦，不，我们还有P-Head，我们有些日子叫P-Head，还有Sonny Boy，我们有很多这样的名字。
What a crew! But believe it or not, can I tell you? Can I tell you, these guys went on to become great lawyers. One guy is a biomedical nuclear engineer for NASA. I mean, come on, you know. Fungus, obviously. So he was the smartest guy in the stupid group. Wow.
好一个团队！但信不信由你，我能告诉你吗？我能告诉你吗，这些家伙后来都成了伟大的律师。有一个家伙是NASA的生物医学核工程师。我的天，真是的，你知道的。Fungus，显而易见。所以他是这群笨蛋里面最聪明的家伙。哇。
The rest of the guys. Wait, so getting back to recall, how good were you at keeping all your memorabilia, news clippings and pictures and things like that? Good? Got them all. You do? Really? You do.
剩下的那些家伙。等等，所以说回回忆，你保存所有的纪念品、剪报、照片以及诸如此类的东西，做得有多好？好吗？全都留着。真的吗？你都留着。
Yeah. How did you know to do that? Was that a mom or a dad thing? that it was like, son, keep your stuff. It was mom, dad, grandma, cousins, aunts, uncles. They kept every clipping. And as they kind of said, I'm wrapping up the house here. So scrapbook after scrapbook after scrap,
对。你怎么知道要这么做的？那是妈妈的主意还是爸爸的主意？就像是，儿子，把你的东西留着。是妈妈、爸爸、奶奶、表亲、阿姨、叔叔。他们保留了每一篇剪报。当他们差不多觉得，我要在这里把房子收拾一下的时候。所以是一本又一本的剪贴簿，
but we've got volumes of the first time I did American Bandstand, the first time of this and the first time I played it. They got it all. And you got it in the book there too? You got pictures of all that stuff? You know what? That's in the, believe it or not, that's the second book coming. That's coming.
但我们有厚厚的好几册我第一次上《美国舞台》杂志时的记录，第一次做这个和第一次演奏的记录。他们全留着。你把这些也在书里了吗？你所有这些东西的照片都有吗？你知道吗？那在，信不信由你，那是第二本要出的书。那本书要出来了。
Wow. Smart. Wow. Let me ask Will and Jay, do you guys do you guys do it or do you have family members that archive your stuff? No. My mom was pretty good about it, and I think I know where some of that stuff is.
哇。聪明。哇。我问一下威尔和杰伊，你们俩，你们俩会这样做吗，或者你们有把你的东西归档的家庭成员吗？没有。我妈妈在这方面挺在行的，我想我知道那些东西有些在哪儿。
I've got some of it. Do you, Sean? I've kind of... Scotty does every single thing I do. Oh, that's cool. That's cool. Believe it or not, you want to lose some of it. It's like living with single white male.
我有一些。你呢，肖恩？我有点……斯科蒂把我做的每一件事都记录下来。哦，这太酷了。这太酷了。信不信由你，有时候你想丢掉一些。这就像跟《单身白人女性》一起生活一样。
Yeah. Do you have candles under it? I sleep with one eye open. Wait, wait, Lina, I want to get into Skeet, if I may. No, I'm kidding. I want to get into, so you start, I love this. Okay, keep going on. Yeah, I'm sure.
对。你会在它下面点蜡烛吗？我睡觉都睁一只眼闭一只眼。等等，等等，莉娜，我想深入聊聊Skeet，如果可以的话。不，开玩笑的。我想深入聊聊，所以你开始，我喜欢这个。好吧，继续说。对，我确信。
I love that you started, so I read some excerpts from your book, and you were talking about you were, you owned a saxophone, and you don't, and you didn't describe yourself as a player, you described yourself as a blower, and these guys were like, hey, man, we might. No, no, I hope I didn't write blower in the book. No, no, I'm, I'm, that's a title of the book, am I right? No, I said, it's saxophone, holder. Holder.
我喜欢你开始的方式，我读了你书中的一些摘录，你提到你曾拥有过一把萨克斯风，而你没有，你没有将自己描述为一个演奏者，你将自己描述为一个吹奏者，而这些家伙就觉得，嘿，老兄，我们可能会。不，不，我希望我没在书里写“吹奏者”。不，不，我是，我是，那是书名，我没说错吧？不，我说的是，萨克斯风，持有者。持有者。
Holder, okay. It's a big difference. It weighs a big difference. Minds ball. It's still a tricky title. Holder blower. But you just kind of had it. You didn't really know how to play.
持有者，好吧。这有很大区别。它的分量有很大区别。这震撼了我的心灵。这仍然是一个诡异的头衔。持有者、吹奏者。但你当时就是拿着它。你其实并不会演奏。
You kind of were able to, you had a musical sensibility to you, and you were able to mimic from stuff that you heard. Is that true? By ear. And not only saxophone, but by piano as well. I cannot read or write music to that point. Wow. Amazing to me.
你有点能够，你有一种音乐敏感度，你能够模仿你听到的东西。这是真的吗？凭耳朵。不仅是萨克斯风，钢琴也是如此。我直到那时都不会识谱或写谱。哇。这对我来说太神奇了。
So what makes it all kind of weird is that when you can pick up a horn and once you figure out, you can now play along with Sunny Stitt or you play along with Cold Train or you play along with you go, okay. And then when you sit down to the piano, you know, it's, you know, once you find out that some of the greatest artists in the world
所以这一切变得奇怪的地方在于，当你拿起一把号，一旦你琢磨透了，你现在就可以跟着桑尼·斯特it（Sunny Stitt）一起演奏，或者跟着科尔特恩（Coltrane）一起演奏，或者跟着你走，好吧。然后当你坐在钢琴前，你知道的，这，你知道的，一旦你发现世界上最伟大的艺术家中有些
cannot read or write music. You know, there's Smokey, there's Paul McCartney. Once you start going down that list of folks, you know, it's a pretty rare fraternity sorority, you know. Now, so did you ever learn or want to learn the names, of course, like the 575 or the 164 or the sharp seventh or whatever that. I can say it. I can talk about it.
是不会识谱或写谱的。你知道的，有史莫基，有保罗·麦卡特尼。一旦你开始顺着那个名单往下看，你知道的，这是一个相当罕见的精英圈子，你知道的。那么，你有没有学过或者想过学那些名字，当然，比如575或164或升七度或者诸如此类的。我能说出来。我能谈论它。
But the point is my problem was ADD or ADHD, which we didn't know back then. Right. So, da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da. Okay, that's great. Now, try to read that on a page with dots. So tracking was the worst thing in the world for me. It wasn't that I couldn't read it. It's just I couldn't read it fast enough to play it.
但关键是我的问题是ADD或ADHD，我们当年并不知道这个。对。所以，哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒。好吧，这很棒。现在，试着在一页长满黑点的纸上读懂它。所以对我来说，视谱是世界上最糟糕的事情。并不是我读不懂。只是我读得不够快，没法把它演奏出来。
Right. Interesting. So when you get in a room, I just forgot all that. And you read a chord chart? Yeah, forget about it. Forget it. You can't read a chord chart, which just says this chord than this chord. I can get it done faster by standing in a room with a group of musicians, hum it to them.
对。有趣。所以当你走进一个房间，我把那些全忘了。你能看懂和弦图吗？对，忘了吧。忘了吧。你看不懂和弦图，也就是写着这个和弦然后那个和弦的那种。我通过和一群音乐人站在一个房间里，把旋律哼给他们听，能更快地搞定。
Wow. That's amazing. And they are so gifted that what you do is by the time I finish the hum, they've already played it six times over. Well, that's what I'm blown away, all of the hit songs. that we all know through all of these years that came out of your head. Like, it's just fascinating to think about how did those melodies and those things come to into your head?
哇。太神奇了。而且他们非常有天赋，你所做的是，当我哼完的时候，他们已经把它反复演奏了六遍了。好吧，这就是让我震撼的地方，所有这些热门歌曲。我们这么多年来都知道的，都是从你脑子里蹦出来的。就像，去想那些旋律和东西是怎么跑到你脑子里的，这太迷人了？
It's just amazing. That's the weirdness of the God gift. You know what I'm saying? I look at actors. I look at comedians. I look at, and I go, you know, how did you put that together in your head? And sometimes they say that was improv, you know, half of that was this.
这真是太神奇了。这就是上帝赐予的天赋的奇妙之处。你知道我在说什么吗？我看演员。我看喜剧演员。我看，然后我想，你知道的，你是怎么把这些在脑子里组合起来的？有时他们会说那是即兴发挥，你知道，其中一半是这样的。
But how do you explain it, though? Do you just hum whatever you're feeling? For me, for me, if I told you there's a radio station playing right now, and all I have to do is tap over into it. Now, it's only 12 notes. Here's the magic of this. It's not like I can go cheat on a lot of words and stuff. There's only 12 notes here, guys.
但你如何解释呢？你只是哼出你当时的感受吗？对我来说，对我来说，如果我告诉你现在有一个广播电台在播放，我所要做的就是调过去。现在，总共只有12个音符。这就是它的神奇之处。这并不是说我可以在很多歌词之类的事情上作弊。这里只有12个音符，伙计们。
And so what happens is you have to know, all you need is four chords. and that's a whole album, you know, believe it or not. So what happens is just knowing what notes to put together, and believe it or not, I can hear that. Right, that's amazing. You know what I'm saying? And we will be right back. And now back to the show.
所以发生的情况是，你必须知道，你只需要四个和弦，那就是一整张专辑，你信不信由你。所以发生的情况就是，只要知道把哪些音符放在一起，信不信由你，我能听得出来。对，太神奇了。你知道我在说什么吗？我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。
Have you enjoyed how it's changed over the years in your own head? because any natural gift does morph sometimes to the better, sometimes to the worse, as your taste evolves and as you allow yourself to be influenced by things that you like and as we get older and tempo and all that stuff, have you enjoyed that process, how your music has changed a bit? In love with it. You know, what happens is, you know, remember, it's all texture.
你喜欢它在你的脑海中这些年来的变化吗？因为任何天赋有时都会发生变化，有时变好，有时变坏，随着你的品味演变，随着你允许自己受你喜欢的事物的影响，随着我们变老以及节奏等等，你喜欢这个过程吗，你的音乐发生了一些变化？非常喜欢。你知道，发生的情况是，你知道，记住，这全是质感。
It's all, you know, sounds. It's, you know, it's all about sonics. So when you can, I started off probably about the first five years, six years, on a grand piano. Yeah. Got it? And then after probably Penny Lover, probably after that, never played that again, grand piano because technology came in and you can get sounds on the keyboard. Yeah. So from that point on, I never played the same keyboard twice.
这全都是，你知道，声音。这全都是，你知道，这全都是关于声学的。所以当你可以的时候，我大概在前五年、六年开始时用三角钢琴。是的。懂了吗？然后在《Penny Lover》之后，大概在那之后，再也没有弹过三角钢琴，因为科技进来了，你可以在键盘上得到声音。是的。所以从那时起，我再也没有弹过同一个键盘两次。
do you remember moments like Sean was saying where the songs come from is of do you have you must have memories of like when you first started to write or hum or come up with you know endless love let's say
你还记得像肖恩刚才说的那样，歌曲的灵感来源的时刻吗？你一定有这样的记忆，比如当你第一次开始写歌、哼唱或创作出，比方说《无尽的爱》
or all night long do you remember like were you standing in the kitchen and you were like getting a glass of milk or you know what I mean? Yeah no it's so many stories about I'll use I'll use probably all night long
或者《All Night Long》，你还记得吗？当时你是不是站在厨房里，正准备去拿一杯牛奶，或者你知道我的意思吗？是的，不，有太多关于这个的故事了，我会用，我可能会用《All Night Long》
I'll use hello as the perfect example. Yeah, great song. I wrote, again, my co-producer James Carmichael was late for the little writing session we were having, and he walks in the door, and I'm just playing on the piano, and I said, hello, isn't me you're looking for, and I played the chords. No way.
我以《Hello》作为最完美的例子。是的，一首伟大的歌曲。我写的时候，我的联合制作人詹姆斯·卡迈克尔（James Carmichael）开会迟到了，他走进门，我正在弹钢琴，我说：“Hello, is it me you're looking for?”，然后我弹了和弦。不会吧。
I was waiting for him to say, yeah, I'm here. Okay, let's get started. He said, finish that song. Wow. So you already had the melody, and the lyrics just came as kind of a joke to... All I had was, hello, is it me you're looking for? Which is the corniest thing I could ever think about in life.
我当时在等他说：“对，我在这。好吧，我们开始吧。”他说：“把那首歌写完。”哇。所以你当时已经有了旋律，而歌词只是作为一种类似玩笑的东西冒出来的……我当时只有：“Hello, is it me you're looking for?” 这可以说是我一生中想到的最老套的事情了。
Oh, my God, it's so great, though. So if you really want to know the backstory of this, which I will tell you, the backstory to this is I didn't like it. I hated it. And he kept saying, finish it, finish it. I said, James, this is... I'll be the laughing stock of the business. Who's going to write a song called Hello, is it me you're looking for?
哦，天哪，不过这太棒了。所以如果你真的想知道这背后的故事，我会告诉你，背后的故事是我不喜欢它。我恨死它了。而他一直说：“写完它，写完它。”我说：“詹姆斯，这是……我会成为业界笑柄的。谁会写一首叫《Hello, is it me you're looking for》的歌？”
And so enough, I finished the song And then I fell in love with it And he hated it Because he was going, okay Because he put the strings on it It was very heavy, heavy, heavy So are you ready for this? We threw it off the album
不出所料，我写完了这首歌。然后我爱上了它。而他却讨厌它。因为他说，好吧，因为他给它配了弦乐。这非常沉重，非常沉重，沉重。所以你准备好听这个了吗？我们把它从专辑里删掉了。
And I wrote a song called Truly To replace it Of course, yeah, no way And then of course the next album We said, well, let's go back and put that hello thing on and that became the national anthem of as I walk around the world hello Lionel
然后我写了一首叫《Truly》的歌来代替它。当然，是的，不会吧。然后当然在下一张专辑里，我们说，好吧，让我们回去把那个《Hello》的东西放上去，这就成了我环游世界时的国歌，你好，莱昂内尔。
yeah it's amazing of course although truly truly was the number one single too so truly was the first believe it or not Grammy wow oh wow after all these songs everyone said well you won the Grammy no no no no you go to the Grammys
是的，这太神奇了。当然，尽管《Truly》也是单曲榜第一名，所以《Truly》是第一首，信不信由你，格莱美。哇，哦，哇。在所有这些歌之后，每个人都说，哦，你赢得了格莱美。不，不，不，不，你去参加格莱美
and you just kind of sign up for your seat but they don't give me anything for the first 10 years of your life and then finally you walk up one day and they call off truly and I said well that's pretty cool and that was the beginning of the ride. Is that often the way that it has worked for you
你只是去那里签到你的座位，但在你人生的前十年他们什么都不会给你。然后终于有一天你走上去，他们叫出了《Truly》，我说，嗯，这挺酷的，这就是这段旅程的开始。这通常是它为你运作的方式吗？
where you come up with, you write a bunch of melodies and then you write a bunch of lyrics and you sort of find what lyrics go with what melodies? Are they that separate? My mother was an English teacher. So I caught hell just trying to go to school every day and using the proper English.
你创作，你写一堆旋律，然后你写一堆歌词，然后你找出什么样的歌词与什么样的旋律相配？它们是那么分开的吗？我母亲是一名英语老师。所以我光是为了每天去学校并使用正确的英语就吃尽了苦头。
So mom, can I go somewhere? I don't know. Can you? That kind of situation. So, you know, my problem with trying to write lyrics, was, or should I say write a song, is, what's the subject? So whatever the subject is, that's the most important thing. It's called the hook. So if you write all night long, right, or you write hello,
所以，妈妈，我能去某处吗？我不知道。你能吗？那种情况。所以，你知道，我试图写歌词的问题是，或者我应该说写一首歌，主题是什么？所以无论主题是什么，那都是最最重要的东西。这叫做副歌（hook）。所以如果你写了《All Night Long》，对吧，或者你写了《Hello》，
or whatever the case may be, then if you have the hook, you'll write now the verses. It's only four lines perverse, but you have to go back and put that together. My problem was I would never write the verses until the Commodore said, we like it because there's nothing worse than finishing a song and you get halfway through
或者无论什么情况，如果你有了副歌，你现在就可以写主歌了。每首主歌只有四行，但你必须回去把它们组合在一起。我的问题是，在Commodores乐队说“我们喜欢它”之前，我绝不会去写主歌，因为没有什么比完成了一首歌却在进行到一半时
now you spent your whole life on this thing and all of a sudden they say we hate it next yeah right right so I would just go here's the hook I'm not gonna put any more work in I'm not putting any more work but then the actual music
你把整个人生都花在这上面了，而他们突然说“我们讨厌它，下一个”还要糟糕，对吧？所以我就去说：“这是副歌，我不想再多费力气了。我不想再多费力气了。”但实际上音乐
for said lyrics just comes much later you just figure out what melody might match this story it's da-a's it's all da-a's and occasionally you go perfect example is a lady you know I'm your night in shining armor and I love you
为了这所谓的歌词，要晚得多。你只是弄清楚什么样的旋律可能与这个故事相配。全都是“da-a's”，全都是“da-a's”，偶尔你会发现，完美的例子就是一首情歌（Lady），你知道的，“I'm your knight in shining armor and I love you”，
da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da that's that uh-huh you just don't know the word you follow me you know penny lover it's almost like I call an answer yeah you just kind of throw it out that now there's some what we call God's words which is why you're writing the song some mumbles comes out in real words
da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da，就是那个，嗯哼。你只是不知道歌词，你跟着我，你知道《Penny Lover》，这有点像呼应，是的，你只是把它抛出来。现在有一些我们称之为“上帝的话语”的东西，也就是你在写歌时，一些含糊不清的声音变成了真正的词句
yeah well you want to hold those as much as possible because that's the true essence of where the other side was trying to direct you really but what about the great luck that your ear has such incredible taste in what a melody sounds like and you also have a voice that is incredible as well like you've got both of these enormous talents it's just it's a perfect storm there are a few others but not many my god you you have just um um um done my gratitude mantra, first thing I get up in the morning,
是的，好吧，你希望尽可能多地保留这些，因为那是另一方试图指引你的真正精髓，真的。但是，你的耳朵对什么样的旋律才叫好听有着如此不可思议的品味，而且你还拥有一副同样不可思议的嗓音，这种巨大的好运又如何呢？你同时拥有这两种巨大的天赋，这简直是一场完美的风暴。还有其他一些人，但不多。天哪，你刚刚……完成了我的感恩咒语，我早晨起床做的第一件事，
the last thing I say at night. You know, how did it ever happen to me? Holy crap. I mean, you know, I mean, you think about very serious things in life, and you don't really think about it. It was someone said years ago, when you're 19, 20, 25, and you win Wimbledon, and you go, wow, you know, where are we going to eat tonight?
我晚上睡觉前说的最后的话。你知道，这怎么会发生在我身上？该死的。我的意思是，你知道，我的意思是，你会想到生活中非常严肃的事情，而你并没有真正去想它。多年前有人说过，当你19岁、20岁、25岁，你赢得了温网，然后你会说，哇，你知道，我们今晚去哪里吃？
Yeah. And then you turn 50, and you go, I want Wimbledon? you know what it's only looking back that you realize holy crap what that's right what was that all about i'm i'm so glad that you know we ask people that sometimes on the show you know do you allow yourself to to pat yourself on the back and and appreciate where you are where you've been where you're going all that stuff it sounds like you've got such a healthy relationship with uh and perspective on your on your life and your gifts and and i was going to that was going to be my next question is you know you just you see
是的。然后你到了50岁，你会说，我赢了温网？你知道，只有在回首往事时，你才会意识到，该死的，那是什么？那是怎么回事？我太高兴了，你知道，我们有时会在节目中问人们，你知道，你允许自己拍拍自己的背，欣赏你现在的位置、你曾经去过的地方、你将要去的地方，所有这些吗？听起来你和你的生活、你的天赋有着如此健康的相处方式和视角，而我正要问，这就是我的下一个问题，你知道，你只是看到
like such a lovely man how would you tell that to my kids please i would suspect jb if i can if i could jump onto your question before you finish it and just say what i notice is you you mentioned early on that you got all your old buddies back and where you grew up and that you're really still in touch with um i forget it was fungus fungus fungus no no oh yeah fungus fungus fungus and all these and all these guys and the and i think the idea that you stay so in tune in touch with them probably has a lot to do with getting their perspective
就像这么一个可爱的人，你让我怎么跟我孩子们说啊，拜托，如果可以的话，莱昂内尔，我想插一下你的话，在你把话说完之前，我想说我注意到的是，你早些时候提到过，你找回了所有老伙计，还有你长大的地方，你真的还和……呃，我忘了，是 Fungus、Fungus、Fungus，不，哦对，Fungus、Fungus、Fungus，还有所有这些人保持着联系，而且我觉得，你能和他们保持如此默契和紧密的联系，可能很大程度上是因为能从他们那里获得
that you have. Yeah, the beautiful part about this now, when I tell you how long we've known each other, then you're really going to know how strange it is and wonderful at the same time. I've known these guys since preschool, elementary school, high school, college. Wow, wow.
那种视角。是的，现在最美好的部分是，当我告诉你我们认识多久了，你才会真正明白这种感觉有多奇妙，同时又有多不可思议。我从学前班、小学、中学到大学就认识这些家伙了。哇，哇。
That's really cool. I mean, honestly, and by the way, every month, we have a Zoom call. Oh, that's great. Really? And we talk about, just like you're sitting here talking now, We've got Zoom calls and we're sitting there talking about
这真的很酷。我是说，真的，而且顺便说一句，我们每个月都会开一次 Zoom 视频会议。哦，太棒了。真的吗？我们会聊一些事情，就像你现在坐在这里聊天一样，我们开着视频会议，坐在那里聊
what you're doing and what's happening and who's doing what and what hurt you. Sorry, Shania, my question was going to be really more about like the how many times did you was it ever tempting because we live in such a permissive
你在做什么，发生了什么，谁在做什么，以及是什么让你受伤。抱负，仙妮亚，我本来想问的问题其实更像是，你有多少次，曾一度感到诱惑，因为我们生活在一个如此纵容
culture and business you know, like you're allowed to be your worst part often. Right. And was it, were you conscious of making the choice to stay as, sorry to use the word again, lovely as you are, you know, like it could be because it's easier. It's to be lazy and to be nasty and to allow people to sort of, you know, clean up after you and care for, like, do you know what I mean?
文化和商业中，你知道的，比如你常常被允许表现出你最糟糕的一面。没错。而你，你是否有意识地选择保持——抱歉再次用这个词——和你一样可爱，你知道的，因为这其实更容易。当个懒人、当个讨厌鬼、让别人来帮你收拾烂摊子并照顾你——比如，你知道我的意思吗？
Like, you're, there's just, it's a choice to stay kind. And I wonder if that would, would they're strong? with that. Well, I'll be honest with you. I kind of grew up in a magical family a little bit here. I used to go back and ask my grandmother every day. I said, Grandma, how do you have so much wisdom? You know so much about life, but you've not been around the world. I've been around the world. How are you able to hold on to your core? And she said, if you learn how to treat people right at home, the rest of the world is easy. An asshole is an asshole. you know and period and so again we're in this business we're called it's called the entertainment
就像，你，这只是一种选择，选择保持善良。我想知道这是否……他们在这方面很强？说实话，我其实是在一个有点神奇的家庭里长大的。我以前每天都会回去问我奶奶。我说，奶奶，你怎么会有这么多的智慧？你对生活了解这么多，但你又没有去过世界各地。我去过世界各地。你是怎么做到初心不改的？她说，如果你学会了在家里如何正确地对待别人，世界上的其他地方就很容易了。混蛋就是混蛋。你知道的，就这么简单。所以再次回到这个行业，我们身处这个行业，它被称为娱乐
business we run across enough assholes every single day yeah so we kind of if you the motto that i have if you can spot one you make sure you don't act like him or her yeah we we came we we came across an asshole recently and uh let me tell you something we i'm not joking and we The three of us sort of appreciated getting that contrast of seeing that grade A-a-a-hole behavior in a way gave us the perspective. And it's funny, I was saying to one of my sons, my 15-year-old today, I was driving to work,
圈，我们每天都会遇到足够多的混蛋，是的，所以如果我们有这样一个座右铭：如果你能认出一个，你就要确保自己不要像他或她那样行事。没错，我们最近遇到过一个混蛋，呃，我跟你讲个事，我不是开玩笑，我们三个人其实挺感激能有那种对比的，看到那种 A 级混蛋的行为，在某种程度上让我们开阔了眼界。很有意思，我今天开车去上班时，对我其中一个儿子——我那个 15 岁的儿子说，
and I said, hey man, I said, we're just talking about moving through life, and I said, you know what, dude, if the only piece of advice I can give you is, no matter what, if you keep pushing out love, even in moments where you feel like you're not getting what you get, If you push it out, it creates a world where you get it back from the universe a million times.
我说，嘿，伙计，我说，我们刚才在聊如何经历生活，我说，你知道吗，老兄，如果我能给你的唯一建议就是，无论如何，如果你不断散发爱，即使在你觉得自己没有得到应得的东西的时刻，如果你把爱散发出去，它就会创造一个让你从宇宙中获得百万倍回报的世界。
So love on people, be kind to people when you run into them, talk to people, not just here at home, we have a loving environment, but also out in the world, and it will come back and you and your experience, and don't do it with the hope of getting a result. Just do it. That's right. I had the wonderful pleasure of watching my dad.
所以去爱别人，当你遇到别人时要对他们好，去和别人交流，不仅仅是在家里这个充满爱的环境中，还要在外面广阔的世界里，它会回报给你和你的经历，而且不要抱着为了得到回报的心态去做。去做就是了。没错。我有幸亲眼看着我爸爸
We have to go, sorry. That was the last thing. Kidding. No, go on, go on, go on. I had the pleasure of watching my dad. You know, he was one of those guys that, you know, I just couldn't figure him out at the beginning. He would walk up to people and, you know, you could tell that he was a lover of people. And so he would come home some days and bring a man home to the house.
我们得走了，抱歉。那是最后一件事。开玩笑的。不，继续，继续，继续。我有幸看着我爸爸。你知道，他是那种一开始让我琢磨不透的人。他会走到别人面前，你知道，你能看出他是一个热爱人类的人。所以他有时会带一个男人回家。
And he would, Bert put on, that's my mother, Alberta. Bert put on another plate. This is Bill, Bill, Bert, Lionel, Deborah. And so he said, I'll be back. I'm going upstairs for a minute. And so here's the guy at the table, Bill, and so my mother starts asking questions. So did you, were you, do you work with Lionel? I'm a junior, so my dad's Lionel.
然后他会喊：伯特，多摆一副碗筷——那是我妈妈，阿尔伯塔。伯特，多摆一副碗筷。这是比尔，比尔，伯特，莱昂内尔，黛博拉。然后他说，我一会儿就回来。我要上楼一分钟。于是比尔这个家伙就坐在桌旁，我妈妈就开始问问题。所以，你，你是，你和莱昂内尔一起工作吗？我是小莱昂内尔，所以我爸叫莱昂内尔。
Okay. So have you worked with, are you working with Lionel? No, no, ma'am. Were you in the military with Lionel? No, ma'am. Are you all friends from where he grew up? No, ma'am. Well, where did you meet Lionel?
好吧。所以你跟……你在和莱昂内尔一起工作吗？没有，没有，夫人。你曾和莱昂内尔一起参军吗？没有，夫人。你们都是他从小长大那个地方的朋友吗？没有，夫人。那你们是在哪认识莱昂内尔的？
Why are you here? He said, well, I just met him at Kroger's. So now my mother leaves the table to go upstairs and ask my dad. Yeah, who the hell is this guy? Who's this guy, right? And of course, Debra and I, my sister, we go upstairs to hear this conversation because we want to know too. And so what the conversation was, he's going to do a job interview tomorrow. and he needs a suit.
你为什么会在这里？他说，哦，我刚在克罗格超市遇到他。于是我妈妈离开餐桌上楼去问我爸。没错，这家伙到底是谁？这人是谁啊？当然了，我和我妹妹黛博拉也上楼去听这段对话，因为我们也想知道。所以对话的内容是，他明天要去参加一个工作面试，
And my dad is reaching in the closet to get a suit that fits him in a tie and stuff. That's amazing. And my mother would say this argument, well, Lionel, it's one of your favorite suits. He says, I can get another suit. The man needs a suit to look the part. Lionel, I love that so much.
他需要一套西装。而我爸爸正在衣柜里找一套适合他的西装、领带之类的东西。这太惊人了。我妈妈就会反驳说，好吧，莱昂内尔，这是你最喜欢的西装之一。他说，我可以再买一套。这个人需要一套西装来撑门面。莱昂内尔，我太喜欢这个故事了。
So you had a great example your whole life. Mike, I was just telling somebody to this story reminds me so forgive me but but it's just i love that and and my grandfather my mom's dad who was really close i was just telling somebody the last couple days this story he was a great guy and i was really really close with him and he used to bring guys back he'd he'd bring he help out he wasn't an alcoholic he'd bring guys back from halfway house and make my grandmother bring him make him a meal and he'd let them work he'd pay them and then he'd talk to them he died at 97 wow everybody who were his friends his peers had died long years before
所以你一生都有一个很好的榜样。迈克，我刚才正跟某人讲这个故事，这让我想起了……所以请原谅我，但……但我就是喜欢这个，还有我外公，我妈妈的爸爸，我和他非常亲近。过去这两天我正跟某人讲这个故事，他是个伟大的人，我和他非常非常亲近。他过去常常把一些人带回家，他会去帮忙——他不是个酒鬼——他会把流浪汉收容所的人带回家，让我奶奶给他们做顿饭，让他们干活，付给他们工钱，然后和他们聊天。他去世时 97 岁，哇，他所有的朋友、同龄人都很多年前就去世了。
And I was just saying the remarkable thing was that church was packed. Yeah. Because he reached, he did stuff for people, young people all the time. I couldn't believe it. I was like, this guy's 97. This church is packed. Yeah, that's so cool. You know?
我刚才就说，最了不起的是，那座教堂座无虚席。没错。因为他总是向别人伸出援手，一直为年轻人做事情。我简直不敢相信。我当时想，这人 97 岁了，教堂居然挤满了人。对，太酷了。你知道吗？
That's a testament to his whole life. Yeah. In college, I would bring guys home. No question. Sean, we're just going to, let's go to a break. Yeah. Sean. Wait
这是对他一生最好的证明。对。上大学时，我也把同学们带回家。毫无疑问。肖恩，我们正准备，我们去休息一下吧。好的。肖恩。等等。
Yeah, it was a totally different story Please let me come back I want to come back to this far I want to come back please No suits I was giving no suits No you were taking off suits Hey listen Lionel Can you can you
是的，这是一个完全不同的故事。请让我回来，我还想回到这个话题，我想回来，求你了。不要西装。我当时没送西装。不，你当时在脱西装。嘿，听着，莱昂内尔，你能……你能……
Ripping him off Can we You started Your first band was the Commodore Your first big band was the Comed Can you talk a little bit about your experience How that happened And then how you gradually moved away
把衣服扒了。我们可以……你开始……你的第一支乐队是海盗乐队（The Commodores）。你的第一支大乐队是……你能稍微聊聊你的经历吗？这是怎么发生的？然后你又是如何慢慢转型
And went on a solo career Just walk us through that a little bit, if you don't mind. Well, yeah, I was going to say that's a whole session by itself. Well, okay, I'm back in school, and it's my freshman year, and of course, I run across this guy on campus, and he says, you know, do you play any instruments? And I said, well, yeah, I'm a fabulous horn holder, you know. I didn't tell him that I brought the horn to school to learn how to play it, but he didn't ask that, so I didn't tell him.
走上个人发展道路的？如果你不介意的话，给我们简单讲讲这个过程吧。好吧，是的，我本想说这本身就是一整场访谈。好吧，好的，我当时回到学校，正读大一，然后当然，我在校园里遇到了这家伙，他说，你知道，你玩什么乐器吗？我说，哦，是的，我是个出色的号手，你知道的。我没告诉他我把号带到学校是为了学着怎么吹，但他没问，所以我也没说。
Hornholder, yeah. So, you know, he said, well, we're starting a band. There's going to be a freshman talent show. And basically what the freshman talent show was, is that all the seniors in upperclassmen would come in and laugh at the freshman. So, you know, we put this band together. And believe it or not, at the freshman talent show,
号手，是的。所以，你知道，他说，我们在组建一支乐队。会有一次大一新生才艺秀。基本上，大一新生才艺秀的意思是，所有大四学生和高年级学生都会来看热闹，嘲笑大一新生。所以，你知道，我们组建了这支乐队，信不信由你，在大一新生才艺秀上，
we killed it. Killed it by you just surprised everybody. Well, you guys just had chemistry? Like you just vibe. Yeah, that's wild. You know, and back then all you had to play was James Brown, and you got it, you know. So you guys covered a few songs?
我们全场炸裂。全场炸裂是因为你们惊艳了所有人？好吧，你们只是很有化学反应？就像你们很合得来。对，太疯狂了。你知道，那时候你只需要演奏詹姆斯·布朗的歌，就能搞定全场，你知道的。所以你们翻唱了一些歌曲？
We did nothing but covers, you know. And so the beautiful part about this was there was a guy in the audience who was in a band called the Jays which is the seniors the greatest band in the world on campus. And so this guy, these guys were graduating and it was two guys that were going to stay around
我们只唱翻唱歌曲，你知道的。所以这其中最美妙的部分是，观众席里有一个家伙，在一个叫 The Jays 的乐队里，那是大四学长，是校园里最棒的乐队。所以这家伙……这些家伙当时要毕业了，其中有两个家伙打算留下来，
because they wanted to put a new band together, Michael Gilbert and Jimmy Johnson. And the next thing we got, a couple of guys, got phone calls. Hey, can you guys stop by? We want to talk to you about putting a band. together well to get a call from them was like it yeah and so we put the band together the next thing we know we have a band called the commodores that's just nuts that's just nuts we played
因为他们想组建一支新乐队，迈克尔·吉尔伯特和吉米·约翰逊。接下来我们收到了一些电话。嘿，你们能顺便过来一下吗？我们想跟你们聊聊组建乐队的事。能接到他们的电话简直就像是……对，于是我们组建了乐队，随后我们就拥有了一支名为 The Commodores 的乐队，这简直太疯狂了，简直太疯狂了。我们在
every sorority house every frat house every campus from here to there and then how did the song writing how did the songwriting start so you're starting you're doing covers and all this and you're like hey we should write our own tunes yeah well that's a whole story i mean it's good though because You know, we could cover everything. You want Slystone, we got Slystone. What do you want? Temptations, we're a temptation. You want three dog night, we got three dog night. Whatever you need, we can play it.
每个女生联谊会宿舍、每个男生兄弟会宿舍、从这头到那头的每个校园演出，然后呢，歌曲创作是怎么开始的？所以你一开始在唱翻唱之类的，然后你觉得，嘿，我们应该写自己的曲子？嗯，那可说来话长了，不过这也挺好，因为你知道的，我们什么都能翻唱。你想要斯莱·斯通（Sly Stone），我们有斯莱·斯通。你想要什么？诱惑乐队（Temptations），我们就是诱惑乐队。你想要三只狗之夜（Three Dog Night），我们有三只狗之夜。不管你需要什么，我们都能演奏。
And then it got to the point where we're trying now to figure out, okay, I think it's time for us to put a record out, right? It's going to happen. And so we started doing auditions. Well, we went to one audition that changed the whole trajectory of what we're going to do. And that was Philly International, Gambling Huff. and we went in and we played every song we killed it
后来到了这个阶段，我们现在开始琢磨，好吧，我觉得是时候出一张唱片了，对吧？这总得发生。于是我们开始参加试听。结果我们去了一次试听，彻底改变了我们接下来要做的事情的轨迹，那就是费城国际唱片公司（Philly International），吉姆布尔和霍夫（Gamble and Huff）。我们走进去，演奏了每一首歌，我们发挥得淋漓尽致。
it's bam we nailed it and right after that something happened the guy came back and said guys you all killed it we said right we got a recording contract right he said no he said
简直是砰的一声，我们完美拿下。紧接着，事情发生了，那家伙走过来说，伙计们，你们太棒了。我们心想，对吧？我们拿到唱片合约了吧？他说，没有，他说，
what we were thinking the whole time you were playing was because by the way you sound just like Slystone you sound just like the temps you sound just like who do you guys what do you sound like wow and I said
我们听你们演奏时满脑子想的是，因为顺便说一句，你们听起来太像斯莱·斯通了，你们听起来太像诱惑乐队了，你们听起来太像……你们到底像谁？你们到底是个什么风格？哇哦。我说，
ah he said i mean i mean we just waiting on what you guys sound like that was the mission of the only way we find out who we are is we got to start writing right and then did you guys sit down and say okay well who what what songs do we really like covering which are the ones we really explode with you know is it more of a sly sound is it more of it yeah that's when the individuality came in that's when the individuals started catching up some guys loved funk Some guys love, I'm a James Taylor nut. I was a Carol King thing, you know, I was a, you know, I could name it, you know, so I was over there. Then I realized, okay, I'm a Stevie person, I'm a Marvin person, you know, that was my wheelhouse.
啊。他说，我的意思是，我的意思是，我们一直在等待你们到底是什么风格。那次使命的意义在于，我们发现自己是谁的唯一方法，就是必须开始自己创作。然后你们坐下来讨论，好吧，那么，我们到底最喜欢翻唱哪些歌？哪几首是能让我们彻底引爆全场的？你知道的，是更偏向斯莱的风格，还是更偏向……对，这就是个性开始显现的时候。这时候每个人开始展现个人特色，有些家伙喜欢放克（Funk），有些家伙喜欢……我是詹姆斯·泰勒（James Taylor）的狂热粉丝。我喜欢卡洛尔·金（Carole King）的风格，你知道的，我是一个……你知道的，我能说出一大堆，所以我当时更倾向于那边。后来我意识到，好吧，我是史蒂夫（Stevie）的拥趸，我是马文（Marvin）的拥趸，你知道的，那才是我的舒适区。
And then as time went on, okay, now I'm an Elton person. Now I'm a, you know, I was in that piano man kind of thing. Sure. And so I would kind of bring in those kind of songs. Now, the joke with all of this was, if you want to get a record on the Commodore album, don't try to do anything up-tempo because everybody had 10 up-tempo songs.
随着时间推移，好吧，现在我是埃尔顿（Elton）的拥趸。现在我是个，你知道的，我属于那种“钢琴诗人”风格的人。当然。所以我往往会带来那种类型的歌。不过这里面好笑的地方在于，如果你想在 The Commodores 的专辑里收录一首歌，千万别尝试写任何快节奏的歌，因为每个人都有一堆快节奏的歌。
So I figured my niche, okay, I'll bring the only slow song they have. Guaranteed I have a record on them. Because you got to come down a little bit to go back up again when you're putting together a whole album. You got to have that in the album. Gotcha. So the mid-tempo, I got the mid-tempo, I got the music. Mid-tempo killed it.
所以我找到了我的定位，好吧，我会带来他们唯一的慢歌。我敢保证我的歌一定能收录进去。因为当你在制作整张专辑时，你必须先情绪下沉一点，才能再次高亢起来。专辑里必须得有这种起伏。明白了。所以中速歌，我搞定了中速歌，我掌握了音乐。中速歌大获成功。
I got it, all right? And as time went on, Brickhouse, we wrote that together as a group. But mainly the mid-section of this whole thing was covered by, okay, I got you. So the only thing happening was when the slow song came out, that was the hit. Wow.
我搞定啦，对吧？随着时间推移，《Brickhouse》这首歌是我们作为一个团队一起创作的。但主要来说，整个这一段的中坚力量是由……好吧，我明白了。所以唯一发生的事情是，当慢歌一发布，那就是热门金曲。哇。
And then in that time when you were writing those songs, when did you, because you also wrote some songs, like you wrote for Kenny Rogers, you wrote famously, you wrote Lady. I mean. You did? Yeah. God bless. When did you start writing for other artists outside of your own, you know?
然后在你创作那些歌曲的时期，你是什么时候……因为你也写过一些歌，比如你还为肯尼·罗杰斯（Kenny Rogers）写过歌，你最著名的作品之一就是写了《Lady》。我是说。你写过？是的。天佑吾皇。你是什么时候开始为自己乐队以外的其他艺人写歌的呢？
Well, Kenny was an interesting story because of the fact that it was not supposed to be for Kenny. It was supposed to be for the Commodores, yet another slow song for the Commodos. He's doing air quotes, by the way, just for the listener. Thank you. I forgot. Nobody can see this. And so what happens from here, the guys walk in and announce no more slow song. songs. Okay, so that eliminates the brother right here gone. And so now I decided I'm going to put out a religious song called Jesus' Love. So I went left of that and put out a church song. Meanwhile, I got a phone call from Kenny Rogers. Do you have one of those songs, man? I just need, right? And
嗯，肯尼是一个有趣的故事，因为事实上这首歌本来不是写给肯尼的。它本该是 The Commodores 的歌，又一首 The Commodores 的慢歌。他顺便做了一个引号的手势，为了听众说明一下。谢谢。我忘了。没人能看到这个。结果从这里开始，队员们走进来宣布：再也不要慢歌了。好吧，这就直接把眼前这位兄弟给淘汰了。于是我决定发布一首名为《Jesus' Love》的宗教歌曲。所以我剑走偏锋，发了一首教堂歌曲。与此同时，我接到了肯尼·罗杰斯的电话。你手里有那种歌吗，老兄？我只需要一首，对吧？然后
I said, Kenny, I have it, but I don't have time. We're going to go on tour. And I don't really have time to do this, but I'll call you when I get back. Two weeks later, the drummer falls off of his motorcycle, if you can believe drummers and motorcycles. And I called Kenny back and said, I'm back from tour. I got it, right? I got it.
我说，肯尼，我有，但我没时间。我们要去巡演了。我真的没时间弄这个，但我回来后会给你打电话。两周后，鼓手从摩托车上摔了下来——如果你能相信鼓手会骑摩托车的话。我给肯尼回电话说，我巡演回来了。我写好了，对吧？我搞定了。
And so the song was called Baby. Instead of Lady? That's all I had. Baby, I'm your knight in shining armor, and I love you. That's it. And I walk into the studio with him, and I'm used to pitching for Commodore. So he said, so where's the song you got for me?
这首歌当时叫《Baby》。而不是《Lady》？我当时只有这些。宝贝，我是你身披闪亮铠甲的骑士，我爱你。就这些。我和他一起走进录音室，而我习惯了为 The Commodores 推销歌曲。所以他说，那么，你给我准备的歌在哪里？
I said, baby. No way. No, no, no. Excuse me. He told me how much he loved his wife. And at that time, she said, he's a fool. She's a lady. I mean, a real lady.
我说，宝贝。不可能。不，不，不。对不起。他告诉我他有多爱他的妻子。而在当时，她（指他妻子）说，他是个傻瓜。她是个淑女。我是说，真正的淑女。
Okay, now what's the name of your song? I said, lady. That's great. Come on, you got to break your work. I love that. You know, when I was 24 years old, I toured with Kenny Rogers. I was a Christmas elf in his Christmas tour. you played a little elf and you'd come out and you'd bring them up that's right the microphone
好吧，现在你的歌叫什么名字？我说，《Lady》。太棒了。拜托，你得打破常规。我太喜欢这个了。你知道，我 24 岁的时候，曾跟肯尼·罗杰斯一起巡演。我在他的圣诞巡演里扮演过圣诞小精灵。
and a little gift box just give us a little taste john just give us a little taste shot well we'd open our the christmas section uh session with um we need little christmas right this very minute and then um i was always high i like every show i was high in my mind and um but kenny was really nice he was a really good guy yeah that's all i have many many stories but not from that time right now i know He's that guy. You could have stories forever. I could talk forever. Yeah.
你扮演一个小精灵，走出来把那个……没错，麦克风和一个小礼盒递给……给我们讲讲细节，约翰，稍微透露一点细节，约翰。好吧，我们在圣诞环节的开场会唱……我们现在就迫切需要一个小圣诞节，然后……我当时总是处于嗨的状态，我每一场演出脑子里都是嗨的，而且……不过肯尼人真的很好，他是个非常好的家伙。是的，我只有这些，有很多很多故事，但现在先不说那段时期的了。我知道他是那种人。你有一辈子的故事可讲。我可以讲个没完。是的。
Yeah, you guys were good friends for a long time, is that right? Forever. Oh, really? Oh, that's great. He's such a nice guy. He was probably not only my friend, but one of my biggest mentors, really. We'll be right back. And back to the show.
对，你们是很长时间的好朋友，是这样吗？永远都是。哦，真的吗？哦，那太棒了。他是个如此好的人。他不仅可能是我的朋友，也是我最大的导师之一，真的。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。
You wrote a lot of songs like all night long and dancing on the scene. A lot of sort of party. Were you part of a party vibe? I was the party animal. What are you talking about? Were you? Yeah, you know, what's so funny. I mean, everyone keeps thinking,
你写过很多歌，比如《All Night Long》和《Dancing on the Ceiling》。很多那种派对风格的歌。你以前也是派对动物吗？我就是个派对动物。你在说什么呢？你是吗？对，你知道的，最好笑的是。我是说，每个人都一直以为，
oh, you know, Lionel, it's really nice because you're such a street guy. Listen, man, I hung out with P-Funk, okay? It's Parliament Falkadelics. I mean, you know, when you're in Rick James, I mean, come on, guys, that's the class. I mean, yeah, for sure. Where were these years?
哦，你知道的，莱昂内尔，这真的很棒，因为你是个如此接地气的人。听着，老兄，我和 P-Funk 混在一起过，好吗？那是 Parliament Funkadelics（议会放克乐队）。我是说，你知道的，当你和里克·詹姆斯（Rick James）在一起时，我是说，拜托，伙计们，那才是殿堂级的。我是说，是的，当然。这些都是什么时候的事？
So you'd left Alabama. Are you we in Los Angeles now during a lot of this, the Commodore stuff? I would say from 70 to probably 75 was like everybody's going to die or everybody's going to live through it. You know what I'm saying? This was in L.A. or we in New York? It's across the country. L.A., New York, you know, we were all touring.
所以你离开了阿拉巴马。在很多那种时候，比如海韵合唱团（Commodores）的事情发生时，我们现在在洛杉矶吗？我想说，从70年到大概75年，就像是每个人都要死，或者每个人都能挺过去。你知道我的意思吗？这是在洛杉矶，还是我们在纽约？是全国各地。洛杉矶、纽约，你知道，我们都在巡演。
But the only guys that didn't make it till late was the Commodores. P. Funk was already in motion three years before we made it. Wow. And so, you know, Bootsie Collins. I mean, think about this. This is an era where, you know, to get the phone call and say, I'm sorry, this so-and-so died, that was everyday occurrence. Right.
但只有海韵合唱团撑到了最后。P-Funk乐队在我们成名前三年就已经开始活动了。哇。所以，你知道，布西·柯林斯（Bootsie Collins）。我的意思是，想想看。这是一个这样的时代，你知道，接到电话说，“我很抱歉，某某某去世了”，那是家常便饭。没错。
You know, but at the same time, you know, you asked the question, how did I get through it? You know, it's just the fear of dying, you know, because that's what's at the other end of everything you want to try there. But it was such an amazing period because you got a chance to see either what you want to do or what you shouldn't do or you know because what's the end result you're going to die so not too much to think about i wanted to ask you um you know i'm a i watch a lot of documentaries and one of the best ones i've
你知道，但与此同时，你知道，你问了这个问题，我是怎么挺过来的？你知道，这只是一种对死亡的恐惧，你知道，因为那是你想尝试的一切事情的尽头。但那是一个非常了不起的时期，因为你有机会看到你想做什么，或者你不该做什么，或者你知道，因为最终的结果是你都会死，所以没那么多好想的。我本想问你，嗯，你知道，我是一个……我看了很多纪录片，我这辈子看过的最好的纪录片之一，
ever seen my whole life was the making of we are the world and i know that people probably come up to you now because it just came out like a year ago or two years ago god time is flying yeah it was one year ago but i should Tracy should know that that that lano you wrote that with michael jackson jackson right right and and as i'm watching i'm sure i'm so sorry to like bug you about it but i just please bug me i'm sorry enough it's just incredible that you put you with quincy put that group of people together at a time when there were no cell phones no computers no it was literally just phone calls and i hope they call back and then i hope they show up i hope they show up and they did and it's one of the most famous songs in the history of the world you know
就是《天下一家》（We Are the World）的制作过程。我知道人们现在可能会去找你，因为它是一两年前刚发行的——天哪，时间过得真快。对，是一年前。但特雷西应该知道，莱昂内尔，那是你和迈克尔·杰克逊一起写的，对吧？对。而且当我看着的时候，我确信……我很抱歉这样打扰你，但我只想……请打扰我吧。我很抱歉，足够了。最不可思议的是，你和昆西在那个连手机、电脑都没有的年代，把那一群人聚在一起，当时真的只有打电话，然后祈祷他们回电，然后祈祷他们出现，祈祷他们出现。而他们真的出现了，这是世界历史上最著名的歌曲之一，你知道的。
what was that like taking that on? I mean, it's a massive mountain to climb. There's such a wonderful feeling of naive. There's such a wonderful feeling of you don't know it's going to be a disaster. You know, because there's a certain time in your life when you go, this is going to be the greatest thing in the world. You know, and you just hang on to it. And by the way, when we finish this song, we're going to save the world.
承担这件事是什么感觉？我的意思是，这是一座巨大的山峰要攀登。有一种奇妙的无知无畏的感觉。有一种奇妙的感觉，就是你不知道这会是一场灾难。你知道的，因为在你生命的某个时刻，你会想：“这将是世界上最伟大的事情。”你知道，你就紧紧抓住它。顺便说一句，当我们完成这首歌时，我们要拯救世界。
We're going to wipe out hunger. I mean, think about this. We're all there to wipe out. hunger and this is going to happen um and then we start getting into the process of doing it after we finally get all these fabulous artists together i mean that one night was a mountain and a half to climb yeah one night and i don't get one night what time did you finish like five six seven in the morning it was seven o'clock eight o'clock in the morning from we didn't start until two because i was hosting the american music awards american music awards
我们要消灭饥饿。我的意思是，想想看。我们都在那里消灭饥饿，而这将会发生。嗯，然后在我们终于把这些了不起的艺术家聚齐之后，我们开始着手去做——我的意思是，那一个夜晚简直是一座难上加难的大山，真的，只有一个晚上。我不明白，只有一个晚上，你们几点结束的？大概早上五点、六点、七点吧。那是早上七点、八点。我们从两点才开始，因为我在主持全美音乐奖。全美音乐奖……
So from 7 that morning, to go into rehearsal, the following morning, I had rehearsal all the way up until 5 o'clock for when we went on the air. We go on the air, I do the American Music Awards when it's over. Excuse me, by the way. In the middle of all this, one six of these crazy awards. And then at 1 o'clock in the morning, drive over to A&M Studios, and we've got show time. I mean, from that point on, I'm walking in the door
所以从那天早上7点开始，一直去排练，直到第二天早上。我一直在排练，直到下午5点我们要直播的时候。我们开始直播，我主持全美音乐奖，结束后……对不起，顺便说一句，在这一切当中，还得赢得六个疯狂的奖项。然后凌晨1点，开车去A&M录音室，我们要开始录音了。我的意思是，从那一刻起，我走进大门……
and are they there or not? And you have to explain the song probably cold to all of them, right? And this is going to be your part, and this is going to be your part. All they had was if they got a cassette, think about that. If you got the cassette, you're doing good.
他们到了没有？你大概得把这首歌原封不动地向所有人解释一遍，对吧？“这是你的部分，这是你的部分。”他们拥有的只是一盘磁带，想想看。如果你拿到了磁带，那你就算走运了。
Right. Most of them showed up just saying, okay, is Quincy, Michael, Lionel, okay, I'll be there. Yeah. Most of them didn't hear the song until they got there, right. So that just showed your blind faith.
没错。他们大多数人出现时只是说：“好吧，既然昆西、迈克尔、莱昂内尔都在，那我也去。”是的。他们大多数人在到那儿之前都没听过这首歌，对吧。所以这正显示了你们盲目的信任。
And you just stayed up all night. This is the mid-80s. I wonder how you guys stayed up all night. It's crazy to think. And the great words, in the great words of my dear friend, okay, now, where are the drugs? We were talking about Roscoe's, chicken and waffles. He said, yes, that sounds good.
而且你们熬了通宵。这是85年前后。我很好奇你们是怎么熬通宵的。想起来真疯狂。用我亲爱的朋友的话说：“好了，现在，毒品在哪儿？”我们当时正在谈论罗斯科炸鸡和华夫饼。他说：“对，听起来不错。毒品在哪儿？”
Where were the drugs? So then you were up for 24 hours, maybe 25, 26. Yeah, yeah. And that was called the break. But we didn't fall apart until about 10 or 11 o'clock the next day. Yeah. Because now it's over, it's out, the baby's born, you know, we have it. You know, now we, of course, we've got to put it together later.
毒品在哪儿？所以你们醒着有24个小时，也许25、26个小时。对，对。这被称为“中场休息”。但我们直到第二天早上10点或11点左右才彻底崩溃。对。因为现在结束了，完成了，孩子出生了，你知道，我们拥有它了。你知道，现在我们，当然，我们以后还得把它组合起来。
But the fact is, the hardest part was getting it on tape. Yeah, that was the hardest part. And then how was the, it's reach and its effect, the desired effect was accomplished, yes? Oh, killed. The money that it earned and the hunger that it alleviated. Yeah, it still played. It was beyond beyond. I remember.
但事实是，最难的部分是把它录制成磁带。对，那是最大难关。然后呢，它的影响力和效果，预期的效果达到了，对吗？哦，大获成功。它赚到的钱和缓解的饥饿。对，它还在播放。那真是超乎想象。我记得。
I remember calling Quincy on the phone and I said, okay, they were saying we raised 10 million, wow, okay, 10 million. We did 20 million, 20 million, wow, wow. We did 30 million, 30 million in 1980, wow, that's like forever, you know. So I remember calling Quincy after we got to a crazy number
我记得给昆西打电话，我说：“好吧，他们说我们筹集了1000万美元，哇，好吧，1000万美元。”我们筹到了2000万美元，2000万美元，哇，哇。我们筹到了3000万美元，在1980年代筹到3000万美元，哇，那简直是个天文数字，你知道。所以我记得在我们达到一个疯狂的数字后给昆西打电话，
and I said, Quincy did we say we're going to give half the money away or all the money. And Quincy said, don't try it, don't try it, don't try it, ski, don't try it. They'll run us out of town Sean out of curiosity these days What are you using to mop up hunger
我说：“昆西，我们是说要把钱的一半捐出去，还是全部捐出去？”昆西说：“别想了，别想了，别想了，斯基（Ski），别想了。他们会把我们赶出城的。”肖恩，出于好奇，这些天你用什么来擦拭饥饿？
Is it just a I just use my shirt or whatever I'm wearing it at the point Like a sloppy Joe or You know It's incredible It was an impossible time You have to understand
就是……我只用我的衬衫，或者当时身上穿的任何衣服。就像一个肉酱三明治（Sloppy Joe），或者……你知道的。这太不可思议了。那是一个不可能的时期。你必须明白，
Everything was And I would say the next thing They made it work No one saw it coming Yeah Back then we didn't have cell phones We didn't have live streaming So no one saw this coming
一切都是……而且我要说的是接下来发生的事情。他们成功了。没有人预料到这一点。是的。那时候我们没有手机，没有实时直播。所以没有人预料到这一点。
So we can sneak up on the world And so they didn't I remember being a kid I remember watching those Watching you guys and watching Band-Aid And all that stuff and thinking like Seeing all these superstars together Because we didn't have social media
所以我们可以悄悄接近这个世界，他们没有察觉。我记得我还是个孩子的时候，我记得看着那些……看着你们，看着“拯救乐队”（Band-Aid）以及所有这些东西，然后心想……看到所有这些超级巨星聚在一起，因为我们当时没有社交媒体，
Because we didn't have any of it You're like oh my God There's Lina Richie and there's Bob Dylan And Bruce Springsteen and Cindy Lopper And you just go down all these people And they're all in the same room It was a mind blow Get that all in the same room
因为我们什么都没有。你会想：“哦，天哪！那是莱昂内尔·里奇，那是鲍勃·迪伦，还有布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀、辛迪·劳帕……”你顺着这些名字数下去，他们全都在同一个房间里。这太震撼了。能把所有人聚在同一个房间里，
with no managers, no lawyers, no glam squad, no nothing. It was like, and I refer to it as your first day of elementary school. Right. And your mother dropped you off, you know, and you got to go in and kind of deal with the rest of the kids on your own. I mean, Dylan was about to have a heart attack. I mean, but Bob showed up. Let's make that very clear.
没有经纪人，没有律师，没有妆造团队，什么都没有。这就好像——我把它比作你上小学的第一天。没错。你妈妈把你送去学校，你知道的，你得自己进去，一个人跟其他孩子们打交道。我的意思是，迪伦当时差点心脏病发作。我的意思是，但鲍勃确实出现了。我们要把这一点说清楚。
You know, Springsteen, we're all there, Stevie's, we're all that. Ray Charles, we're all there. And we had to kind of walk in and get you. to each other. Did you see a few of them at the AMAs earlier and say, hey, I'm expecting you in a few hours
你知道，斯普林斯汀，我们都在那儿，史蒂夫，我们都在那儿。雷·查尔斯，我们都在那儿。我们不得不走进去，彼此……你之前在全美音乐奖上见过他们中的几个人，并说：“嘿，我期待几个小时后见到你，在派对上放轻松点”吗？我见过几个。而那些刚结束巡演的人让事情变得很困难。换句话说，史蒂夫，好吧，我搞定了。迈克尔，好吧。
and take it easy at the party? I saw a few. And the ones that were coming off tour made it difficult. In other words, Stevie, okay, I got it. Michael, okay.
但迪伦会来吗？是的。我的意思是，他不是那种按常理出牌的人，比如，他可能会来，也可能不会，你知道的。斯普林斯汀是从他在麦迪逊广场花园的最后一场演唱会赶来的，
But is Dylan going to show up? Yeah. I mean, he's not known for, like, is he might, he might not, you know. Springsteen is coming from his last concert in Madison.
哇，哇！但我刚才说什么来着？史蒂夫在费城。是的。费城有一场暴风雪，他可能出不来。哇！明白我的意思吗？是的。顺便说一句，我们没有手机来确切知道他在哪里。对。但你们有应急方案，比如“好吧，那辛迪·劳帕会唱这一段”，或者……是的。我的意思是，这本可能是一场人生的车祸现场。
square garden wow wow but what am i saying stevie was in philadelphia yeah there's a snowstorm in philadelphia he might not get out wow follow me yeah and by the way we have no cell phone to know exactly where he is right but you've got contingencies as far as like well then uh cindy lopper will sing this verse or yeah i mean it could have been the train wreck of life yeah yeah it was wild to see wailon jennings walk out is that by the way it wasn't wild at all whaling was true to his Whaling was, he was walking on ice just a little bit because he was there because of Willie. Really said, this is going to be great.
是的，是的。看到威伦·詹宁斯（Waylon Jennings）走出来太疯狂了。顺便问一句，一点也不疯狂。威伦非常符合他自己的风格。威伦，他当时其实有点如履薄冰，因为他是为了威利（Willie）才来的。威利说：“这会很棒的。”
And everything was fine. You know, good old boy, he's ready to go. And then we started, we're going to put some Swahili in there with Stevie walks in. And the point we said was, don't veer off course. Yeah. Well, Stevie didn't get that memo. And so what happened was Stevie comes in and says,
一切都很好。你知道的，老好人一个，他准备好出发了。然后我们开始准备在里面加入一些斯瓦希里语，这时史蒂夫走进来了。我们当时说的一点是：“不要偏离轨道。”好吧，史蒂夫可没收到那条备忘录。于是发生的情况是，史蒂夫走进来并说：
we need some African phrasing, Tutu why no-no Willie Moingu Right, I remember that Tutu why no-no Willie Moingu and we said that about three times
“我们需要一些非洲风格的措辞：‘Tutu why no-no Willie Moingu’。”没错，我记得那个：“Tutu why no-no Willie Moingu”。我们把那句重复了大约三次，
in Whaling said Ain't no good old boy ever sang no Swahili I'm out of here And he left No way No way
然后威伦说：“没有哪个老好人会唱斯瓦希里语。我走了！”然后他就走了。真的吗？不会吧！
And the joke was It wasn't Swahili But it didn't matter It didn't sound like Good old boy So I'm out You know But we all
而笑话是，那根本不是斯瓦希里语。但没关系，听起来不像老好人会唱的，所以我走人。你知道的。但我们所有人……
When Willie Willie said Well there goes well That goes whaling I said okay Wait wait Wait, wait, wait, I want to know what the, I want to know what the, speaking of like, like, this sort of like just like nonsense or words. There's all, I think it's an all night long way to go.
当威利说：“好吧，威伦走了。”我说：“好吧，等等，等等，等等。”我想知道那个……我想知道那个……说到这种……这种就像是胡言乱语或者词汇的东西。有一个部分，我想是在《All Night Long》里，
There's that part, it goes, on the red do. Oh, Tambolite said the moya, yeah. What is that? It's a wonderful phrase that has gone around the world that means absolutely nothing. Yeah. Say it again. Say it again. No way, no way, say it said.
有这样一部分，唱着：“Tambolite said the moya.”哦，“Tambolite said the moya”，是的。那是什么？这是一个传遍了全世界的奇妙短语，它完全没有任何意义。是的。再说一遍。再说一遍。没门，没门，照我说的说。
Tambolite said demo, yeah, jambu, jambu, jambu. We to patte, oh, we go with. Oh, chambalite said the boy, yeah, right? Now, here's the joke. The joke was I am now trying to find some African stuff, right? And so I go in and I go, let me call the UN. I figured I would call out and I said, I need how stupid I was, I need some phrasing from African dialect that says infectious party.
“Tambolite said demo, yeah, jambu, jambu, jambu. We to patte, oh, we go with.”哦，“Chambalite said the boy, yeah”，对吧？现在，笑话来了。笑话就是，我现在正试图找一些非洲的东西，对吧？于是我走进去，心想：“让我给联合国打个电话。”我当时觉得自己太蠢了，我打电话过去说：“我需要一些非洲方言里表示‘狂热派对’的措辞。”
And the guy said, Lionel, there's 101 African dialects. I said, okay, so let me get this straight. So one part of Africa, he said, one tribe doesn't know what another tribe is saying. Okay, thank you very much. I hang up the phone. Call my friend from Jamaica. I said, when Bob Marley says, yeah, boy, Yanji, you mon, yeah, yeah, what is he saying? He says, absolutely nothing.
那个人说：“莱昂内尔，非洲有101种方言。”我说：“好吧，那我理清一下，非洲的一个部落不知道另一个部落在说什么。”我说：“好的，非常感谢。”我挂了电话。给我在牙买加的朋友打电话。我说：“当鲍勃·马利说‘yeah, boy, Yanji, you mon, yeah, yeah’，他到底在说什么？”他说：“完全没有任何意义。”
Yeah. So they're not getting. You follow me? Okay, so waboo, yeah, yeah. Oh, gee, well, what? Okay, nobody knows what the hell that is. Okay, great. Thank you very much.
所以他们根本不懂。你明白我的意思吗？好吧，所以“waboo, yeah, yeah”。哦，天哪，什么？好吧，鬼知道那是什么。好吧，非常感谢。
Hung up the phone. Tambolite, says, yeah. You had license. Yeah. That's amazing. That is so awesome. So people stop me. I couldn't tell you for the first year.
挂了电话。“Tambolite says, yeah.”你有这个创作自由。是的。这太棒了。这太酷了。所以人们拦住我……第一年里我没法告诉你。
People were saying to me, man, this is so great, man. You're tying the mumbo with mumbo, jumbo, jambo. And they're trying to tell me what it means. And I don't want to tell them. It means nothing. But I went along with it. Then finally, I just had to let the cat out of the bag. That's great.
人们对我说：“伙计，这太棒了，伙计。你把这个和姆博、姆博、詹姆博（mumbo, jumbo, jambo）结合在一起。”他们试图告诉我那是什么意思。而我不想告诉他们其实什么意思也没有。但我还是顺着他们的话说下去了。最后，我不得不把秘密泄露出来了。这太棒了。
I love that. How often are you getting out there enjoying all the love that you deserve from the crowds? Are you still enjoying getting out there and performing live? You do a bunch of dates still? People ask me, you know, how long does your tour last? I said, it's been going on since 71. Yeah. So how it works is very simple.
我喜欢这样。你有多经常出去享受人群本该给予你的所有喜爱？你现在还享受出去进行现场表演吗？你还在安排很多演出日期吗？人们问我：“你知道，你的巡演能持续多久？”我说：“从71年就开始了。”所以它的运作方式很简单。
We just came off of a European tour, 34 dates, from London to drive. Germany to, you name it, U2, O2, the big arenas and a couple of stadiums. And the fact is, it's still happening. I mean, the point is, it's still happening. So when you walk out on stage, there's 100,000 people, you walk out on stage as 40,000 people. And the beautiful part about where it is now is that when I forget the lyrics, I just go, come on. And here we go. Yeah, yeah.
我们刚刚结束了一场欧洲巡演，34场演出，从伦敦到德国，各种地方，巨蛋体育场，大型竞技场和几个体育场。事实是，它仍在继续。我的意思是，重点是，它仍在继续。所以当你走上舞台，面对10万名观众，或者当你走上舞台面对4万名观众时……而现在最美妙的部分在于，当我忘记歌词时，我只要说：“来吧！”然后我们就开始了。
And it gets to the point now where it's even getting to the. point of the Rocky Horror show, they know all the parts. And the next thing they do, they walk out with the mustache, the hair, the afro, the whole thing. And those are the girls. Those are the ladies. So it's really like coming to, I did Glastonbury, which is the whole center of the book. The book starts at Glastonbury and works back. And there's 200,000, let me give you that name, 200,000 people.
现在情况甚至发展到了……甚至有点像《洛基恐怖秀》那种程度，他们知道所有的歌词部分。接下来他们会戴着小胡子、假发、爆炸头，全副武装地出场。而且这些都是女粉丝。都是女士们。所以这真的就像是来到……我去过格拉斯顿伯里音乐节，那是整本书的核心。这本书从格拉斯顿伯里开始，然后倒叙。那里有20万——让我给你这个数字——20万观众，
dressed up like Lionel Ritchie. Wow. And it starts there and goes back to the beginning of, that's where the book is what it's all about. And so how did I get there? And when you see the security guards break out dancing, that becomes, okay, this is a happening. And so, you know, it's really the journey.
打扮成莱昂内尔·里奇的样子。哇。而一切从那里开始，倒回起点，这就是这本书所讲述的全部内容。我是怎么走到这一步的？当你看到保安们也情不自禁地跳起舞来，这就变成了一种……好吧，这是一场盛会。所以，你知道，这真的是一段旅程。
The book is all about the journey. Yeah, the longevity and the level of quality that you've maintained for, so long uh it's just so astonishing it's just really admirable yeah it is you you're just a you're such a like i said you're such a heavy weight you're just an incredible talent and we just uh just admire the heck out of you and your your book truly is on sale september 30th and uh i i urge everybody to get out and and read it and i read a bunch of parts i can't wait to read it it's so interesting and your story is so fantastic man and you bring such positivity you
这本书讲的就是这段旅程。是的，你保持了这么长时间的长青和高质量水平，这太令人惊叹了，真的太令人佩服了。是的，确实如此。你真的是一个……就像我说的，你是一个重量级人物，你是一个不可思议的天才，我们真的……非常钦佩你。你的新书确实将在9月30日上市，呃，我敦促每个人都去买来看看。我读了很多部分，我都迫不及待想读完了，太有趣了，你的故事太棒了，伙计，你带来了如此积极的……
got such a positive vibe. It's infectious. I love it. Yeah. And I'm an MTV baby, so I grew up on you. This is a little surreal to me. It's really, really cool. Well, first of all, I want to thank Will for inviting me.
你有一种如此积极的氛围。极具感染力。我太喜欢了。是的。而且我是伴随着MTV长大的，所以我听着你的歌长大。这对我来说有点超现实。真的非常非常酷。好吧，首先，我要感谢威尔邀请我来。
This has been more fun and aha discovery yet again, you know. But it's wonderful to be able to kind of stay here at the other end. First of all, to be a live clothed in my right mind is probably a phenomenon in our business, you know. Normally what you have at the end of this is, well, when I came out of this clinic or when I came out of this rehab or when I... Sure. The trick is just kind of surviving this business because it's treacherous, as you well know. And so, you know, being a positive light, I've found that there's probably one, well, three simple words,
这比以往任何时候都更有趣，充满了顿悟和发现，你知道的。但能够在这个阶段依然留在这里，感觉真的很奇妙。首先，能够活着并且保持理智，这在我们这个行业里可能就是一个奇迹，你知道的。通常你在经历这一切的最后得到的是：“嗯，当我从这家诊所出来的时候”或者“当我从这家戒毒所出来的时候”或者我……当然。秘诀只是在这个行业里生存下来，因为它险象环生，正如你很清楚的那样。所以，你知道，作为一个积极的光芒，我发现可能有一个——好吧，三个简单的词：
I love you is what the whole world wants to hear. That's right. So I didn't plan it. That's not me planning. It's just, you know, I happen. to get that mission to use those words and it's been it's serving me and end the world well well yeah congratulations on keeping your your your light bright all of these years and untarnished and shining it on all of us we really appreciate it thank you for the the hour you uh yeah hit us thanks for the great lionel richie
“我爱你”是全世界都想听到的。没错。所以我不是计划好的。那不是我策划的。这只是，你知道，我碰巧得到了使用这些词的使命，它一直以来都对我以及对世界很好，很好。是的，祝贺你这么多年来一直保持着你的光芒明亮、毫无瑕疵，并把它照耀在我们所有人身上，我们真的非常感激。谢谢你给我们的这一个小时，呃，是的，谢谢你，伟大的莱昂内尔·里奇。
thank you very much guys what a pleasure pleasure pleasure and i hope our paths cross i promise it's somewhere if you see me out just come over and tap me on the show and say it hey It's me Will, Sean. Come on, hey, Rich, you know. We're going to take you up on that. Thank you, Lionel Richie. Thank you so much. Continue success.
非常感谢你们，伙计们，真是太高兴了，太高兴了，我希望我们的道路能交织在一起，我保证总有一天，如果你看到我，就走过来拍拍我的肩膀说，嘿，我是威尔，肖恩。来吧，嘿，里奇，你知道的。我们会接受你的邀请的。谢谢你，莱昂内尔·里奇。非常感谢。再创辉煌。
This book truly comes out September 30th, Lionel Richie. Thanks for joining us, man. Love you guys. Thank you, Lionel. I love you too. Thanks so much. Bye, palu. Bye.
这本书确实在9月30日发行，莱昂内尔·里奇。感谢你能来，伙计。爱你们，伙计们。谢谢你，莱昂内尔。我也爱你。非常感谢。再见，老兄。再见。
I feel bathed. Me too. Right? Me too. Isn't that it awesome when you meet somebody like that who just brings, like, positivity and you get, like, contrast. Like, just, I don't know.
我觉得全身都沐浴在光芒中。我也是。对吧？我也是。当你遇到这样一个人，他能带来如此多的正能量，并且能给你带来反差感时，那种感觉不是很棒吗？就像是，我不知道。
You know, a lot of musicians that we've had on the show, I don't know what it is. If they've found the thing in such a young age that they love to do, that it feels, it might sound really cheesy, but it seems like they're so connected to their spirit and they're so joyful. Remember when Alicia Keys was on? I was just going to say,
你知道的，我们节目请过很多音乐人，我不知道为什么。如果他们在很小的时候就找到了自己热爱的事业，那种感觉——这听起来可能真的很老套——但他们似乎与自己的精神紧密相连，而且充满了快乐。还记得阿西亚·凯getKeys来的时候吗？我正要说……
she has been my favorite guest because of her light and her energy. And he is a co-eat, those are my kids. two favorite interviews. Lionel Richie and Alicia Keys. Those are very good. I think that you're right, Sean. I don't think it's cheesy at all. I think there is something about musicians
她一直是我最喜欢的嘉宾，因为她的光芒和能量。他是一个，那也是我的孩子们最喜欢的两个采访。莱昂内尔·里奇和阿西亚·凯斯。这些都非常棒。肖恩，我觉得你是对的。我觉得这一点也不老套。我觉得音乐人身上确实有某种特质，
in that way that makes them special. Like you connected to something. I don't know. And then they emit that light. By the way, you know, I ran into out here, you're going to love this, Sean. I forgot to tell you. I ran into, I was at this thing
让他们变得特别。就像你与某种事物建立了连接。我不知道。然后他们散发出那种光芒。顺便说一句，你知道我在外面碰到了谁，肖恩，你会喜欢的。我忘了告诉你。我遇到了，我当时在参加一个活动，
and all of a sudden I fell on the tap on their shoulders and he goes, hey, Will, it's Dave from Depeche Mode. And it was so funny. The way. The way he said, Dave from Depeche Mode. Wait, you was there? He was a sweet guy. Yeah, yeah.
突然有人拍了拍我的肩膀，他走过来，嘿，威尔，我是来自“赶时髦”乐队的戴夫。这太搞笑了。那方式。他打招呼的方式，戴夫来自“赶时髦”乐队。等等，你在那儿？他是个很好的人。对，对。
He was, like, there's like a couple weeks ago, and I go, hey, man, we just, we just, we just died. By the way, you know he's coming to the show on Wednesday. Who? Good night, Oscar. Mark Hamel. No way. Wow. Oh, God.
他就像是几周前在那儿，我说，嘿，伙计，我们当时快笑死了。顺便说一句，你知道他周三要来看演出吗？谁？晚安，奥斯卡。马克·哈米尔。不会吧。哇。哦，天哪。
Scotty works working on his outfit right now. Are you putting, are you going to wear a Depends? Yeah. Or two. Yeah. Oh, gosh. Honestly, I can't get over that, that Latin Richie, though. Yeah, amazing.
斯科蒂现在正在准备他的演出服装。你准备，你打算穿纸尿裤吗？对。或者两条。对。哦，天哪。说实话，对于莱昂内尔·里奇，我真是难以忘怀。是的，太棒了。
And that we know. I know, like I said, I was such an MTV guy. Like, I would see him. I would see him in all the music videos. And the hello video I was going to say, and it became more beautiful because the video with the blind girl, I don't know if you guys remember that.
而且我们都知道。我知道，就像我说的，我曾经是个坚定的MTV迷。我会看他。我会看他所有的音乐录影带。还有《Hello》这首歌的视频，我正要说，而且它变得更加美丽，因为那个视频里有一个盲女，我不知道你们是否还记得。
But it was about this blind woman, and it was beautiful. Anyway, I loved that. The number of hits, that guy has had, he's got to be up there near the top as far as like, number one. It's like 150 million records sold worldwide. And he's that guy.
但这是关于这个盲女的故事，非常美丽。不管怎样，我很喜欢那个。那个家伙拥有的热门歌曲数量，就冠军单曲数量而言，他绝对名列前茅。全球唱片销量大约有1.5亿张。而且他就是那样一个人。
And he's like, hey, what's going on? Yeah. Yeah, he was going on. He's had like, like 10 or 12 number one hits. Like, it's just, it's insane. Yeah, and he's still touring. And it seems like he's 35 years old. No, kidding.
他就像是，嘿，最近怎么样？对。对，他当时就是这样。他大概有10到12首冠军单曲。就像是，这太疯狂了。是的，他还在巡演。而且看起来他才35岁。真的不是开玩笑。
He looks amazing. I know. I know. What an inspiration, man. I want to come back as Lionel Richie. I know. I know. Do you think he'll write a sequel to the song, Hello?
他看起来状态好极了。我知道。我知道。真是个鼓舞人心的人，伙计。我想下辈子投胎当莱昂内尔·里奇。我知道。我知道。你觉得他会为《Hello》这首歌写一首续集吗？
Oh, what would you think it would be called? What kind of a name do you think he could give to it? I mean, if you were going to do a second part to hold on. Well, that's weird. How would you... Where would you even start? I would probably start. At the first time, I would say, goodbye.
哦，你觉得它会叫什么名字？你觉得他可以给它起个什么名字？我的意思是，如果你要拍第二部分，等一下。这有点奇怪。你怎么……你甚至会从哪里开始？我可能会从头开始。第一次的话，我会说，再见。
Me? Is it me or not looking for? We would get your nuts out of the vice first. Goodbye. Bye. Bye. And I don't know that's bad. Bye.
我？是我还是在找……我们得先把你的痛处解决掉。再见。再见。再见。我不知道这好不好。再见。
smart less smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by rob armjarf benet barbico and michael grant terry There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SmartLess是由罗伯·阿姆杰夫、本·巴尔比科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里100%有机手工打造的。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。